for the couple minute delay just trying
to verify some replacements
i do have to read my script as usual for
91a
as chair of the house transportation
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
well as
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-44
his public bond is authorized to meet
electronically
is a public hearing with the potential
for executive session to occur
throughout
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
one all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting
via zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available on the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
uh two the notice for this meeting uh
the notice for this meeting notice
complies with house rules and irsa 91-8
three anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us mr greenland
welcome again our committee researcher
and please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call before
uh let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call of attendance when each member
states their presence please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
thank you and as soon as the clerk is
ready we'll do our roll call that's okay
good morning everybody
yes
uh representative smith
representative hill
yes good morning i am here in my home
alum
thank you representative aaron
here in the committee room good morning
representative
president in my home alone thank you
president foreski
i am here in my house all alone
representative para
i'm here i'm in my office my co-workers
might walk by
thank
you um representative trevor state
was that tallersky yeah i got you out of
order i'm sorry sorry
i'm used to being later in the list i
apologize
um my husband my husband and and two
sons are also at home today
uh representative trojan
representative sykes
representative sykes i'm here and i'm
downstairs in the kitchen my wife is
upstairs thank you representative
cleaver
i'm present i'm home alone
representative pickering
i'm here
i'm in my own room and my wife is also
president in another room in the house
thank you representative gracie
i am here my um i'm in my office at my
home my wife is in the house as well
thank you representative rich
i'm here my husband and my son are here
also
thank you representative fox
i am here
my husband is in the house he is not in
the room
thank you representative stevens
president
no one in the room with me thank you and
representative
i am here alone in my office but my wife
and son are in the house thank you
uh chairman
president president in the room
301 303.
okay thank you thank you very
much we'll open the public hearing
on house bill 515 and act relative to
confidentiality for reporting possible
medically unfit drivers
uh the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor of the bill representative
i did see you're on the attendee list
whenever you're ready representative
o'hara
i could be good he's on you know
there you go
can you hear me now
you can good morning representative good
morning and just as you introduced me uh
my zoom dropped and had to reestablish
yeah that's all good it's probably
because we promoted you to panelists so
that you can be seen on the screen if
you choose
oh okay i did try to dress decently
let's see
okay there we are there you are
thank you that was very nice of you
thank you very much for making me feel
welcome the butterflies are starting to
fight in my stomach
um
i don't care four years i've been here
and i still get nervous
okay the reason
the reason for my um
for my bill is that i had the bad
experience of discovering that a friend
who was driving all the time
husband wanted her to drive
i was at the track with her we were
volunteering for the lions and
i realized she was speaking about her 50
year old children as if they were
in elementary school
so i tried to get her to keep talking
because i couldn't believe it was that
bad well it was
and i wanted to so i called to report uh
the report that i was very concerned so
i called the dmv
and the nice guy who talked to me this
was a few years ago said this is very
good of you responsible to call and ask
us to retest her
but you realize that if she asks us who
made the request we must by law tell her
and because her husband was mentally
unbalanced person who had also already
threatened people so seriously that they
took his gun collection away
which he then re-bought
uh that to one of the other
representatives from salem had actually
had to go down and file a complaint
because after the guy threatened his
wife
so
i chickened out i was afraid to report
her because i was afraid of him and it's
always weighed heavily on my mind that i
didn't do my civic duty because when
you all know that you make
many many split-second decisions when
you're driving and a person who's
impaired really can't do that
so i brought this bill and i realized
that by keeping ourselves confidential
some people immediately say
yes but
somebody could do that to be malicious
well that's true but you could you could
file any kind of complaint to be
malicious
but just in case that would make it more
palatable
i asked for the amendment
which would say that
you wouldn't be confidential but the
person you
asked to be retested
would have to request in writing
so i figured if somebody
really was failing inability
they might be
a kind of slow at writing that letter
uh because it really says we're in
writing and the current rules are
nobody loses their license on one
one uh
intervention
you have to fail a driving test
three times to lose your license
so we're not talking about
any kind of immediate action
when you observe
a friend a neighbor
someone you know
that you feel is really dangerous on the
road
there's nothing you can do to make them
lose their license
all you can do is request that they be
tested
and it's up to them after that up to the
dmv
uh
they
um
yeah because i've been told by people
you know that it sounded like dropping a
sledgehammer on somebody that you just
suspect is a dangerous driver but you
can't our current laws this doesn't do
anything to change our current laws that
you cannot lose your license unless you
fail the written test
and the driving test
three times and this bill also
spells out that the dmv has the right to
review that person before they ever go
send them a letter to schedule a test
they can make some calls and find out uh
if anybody else is aware or if somebody
says no that sounds really nuts you know
this person is is as uh as capable as
you and i
so it's written as flexibly as possible
so i'm happy to take questions
thank you representative
any questions from the committee
representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative gay good morning
i was comparing
this bill to the one we heard last term
and the the one thing that stuck out to
me was the new wording at the beginning
of section two to protect family friend
and professional relationships
and it's just a little bit of a tweak do
you know why that was changed to in that
way
well i was
i was trying to give a reason
because if you didn't care about this
person or you didn't have a close
relationship
what's the problem if they know that
you're the one who requested it
but and like in
it's not just in a case like mine where
he could have been
quite retaliative
the other situation that's more much
more common
is when it's the head of the household
and his wife says
you really shouldn't be driving of
course i'm going to be kicking and
screaming when they take my license away
so it shouldn't be just
a guy not
not being uh driving safely anymore but
in a case of a of a marriage
that's our our parents and kids saying
dad you shouldn't or mom you shouldn't
be driving anymore
uh
it really does serious damage to that
relationship
uh currently doctors
we don't see the pair yes we do
paragraph roman numeral one
that's old
and two doctors testified last time
that they did this with patients and
guess what
the patients just left them
because they can't be sued
but their their identity is also
uh not protected
um
at the senior center i heard that one
woman came in and in front of everybody
she yelled at the director and said did
you turn me in
that's how she looked at it he's turned
her in
she was that was very obviously that she
was a dangerous driver anybody watching
her park and he said yes i did but he
didn't have to worry about the damage of
their relationship
any further
further questions
from the committee representative o'hara
thank you mr chair i just had one quick
question um
is this build more focused on just the
mental ability of the driver because i
did hear you say if they're danger so i
didn't know if you were going to start
if it was going to start going down um
like mexico that's driving
strictly more just to
mental ability of driving
well we were modifying
modifying an old law which is medically
unfit
and if you're
i couldn't hear every word you said
were you talking about
maybe drug induced
you know eli type things
like um speeding and stuff like that
excessive speeding and stuff like that
no
no this really is for medically
medically uh unfit which you know covers
a lot of different causes
okay thank you
thanks
any further question representative
aaron yes thank you mr chair thank you
um
representative gay for coming presenting
this bill
can you hear me okay
okay yes um so i'm just wondering uh
wants to
prevent um somebody from maliciously
uh reporting somebody you know just
saying that they were driving
erratically or whatever
and then putting this person through
you know some sort of
reports or testing or whatever
what what can we do to protect people
from being accused of something
that they didn't do
well there are built-in safeguards
luckily they're already
already in law
are at least in practice in rules
that the identity
of the person who is being uh
asked to be retested i don't know how to
say that
neatly but if you request somebody to be
tested or at least looked at
um because they might not end up being
tested if the person checks out if the
dmv checks this person out before they
ever talk to the person or send them a
letter
and determines that there's no problem
there is no public no public access to
the fact that this person has been
looked at that's current practice
both not only your identity my original
bill is that your identity if you're
requesting this person to be looked at
your identity is protected their
identity is protected too throughout the
entire process from beginning to end
that is not public record
um
and so because you know because of the
concern that somebody would be malicious
um
in paragraph three
some people criticized
uh that because the reporting person's
identity shall not remain con
confidential in any instance where the
division deems the complaint malicious
and somebody said well that's not
that's not clear enough i'm thinking
anybody on this committee knows if
they've been had
and so i i think that's uh that's
reality we know if somebody's uh
claiming something you can
listen to them because you could talk to
them too
um
but that's why i offered the amendment
that said
they're confident the re the person who
makes the request their identity would
not be held confidential
but the
person they asked to be tested
would have to write a letter they
couldn't just call on the phone and say
who you know who made you do this they'd
have to write a letter
and i figure if they're really
incompetent that would be a challenge
follow up
thank you uh chairman
and
so
is there any penalty for um reporting
something like this in a malicious
manner
well they get known
and they look they've lost they've lost
respect because as chances are then the
dmv would ask the police do you have
problem with this driver
because they could say oh yeah they've
had like three fender brenders in the
past two months uh
so they're they're putting their they
have to make this in writing they have
to sign this statement
so they're damaging their own
uh reputation by filing a false claim
representative
thank you mr chairman i actually have a
question of you if you don't mind
sure
um
can you tell us what further witnesses
we may have because my questions might
be more appropriate for them yeah we do
have the only other one i have signed up
is uh
director bilecki from department of
motor vehicles
okay i don't see any other yeah i don't
see on the hands at this time either so
as of now she's the last one
okay thank you uh part of my questions
will wait for her the next the second
question is
i
representative gay i
i you keep talking about an amendment
and do you have an amendment that's been
prepared by ols or is the bill that
you've submitted a change of existing
law
no they she they they were kind enough i
submitted the uh
to ols yesterday morning and at two
o'clock they sent it out so it's just
one
one line that i can read to you that
means that your identity
would not be kept confidential
it's in paragraph two
um
it says let's see
a driver who does not appear to be
capable of driving safely oh the person
who reports in a sign written statement
to the division his or her observation
of a driver who does not appear to be
capable of driving safely shall be kept
confidential here's the addition unless
the reported person submits a written
request to the division
thank you
thank you well if i heard you i heard
you correctly representative did you
said you you just received that
amendment and and we had left yeah that
was that was emailed to us by ols
yesterday at 2.
okay i don't believe i saw her yet so
i'll look i'll look for it okay but
again the the additional wording is just
unless the reported person
submits a written request to the
division
we'll look for it i'll find it
okay and fran nutter of them is
intending to call but she wouldn't be on
the list
any further questions
thank you very much
wait a minute excuse me yeah
mr chairman could we get the um
the amendment number off of that
uh what he has
it's 048
mr chair
the committee received it yesterday from
representative gay herself i got it
yesterday afternoon okay i didn't see it
this morning i left school down
thank you very much
um
any further questions
seeing none thank you again
uh next up the chair recognizes uh
director belecki from the new hampshire
department of motor vehicles
who is opposed to the bill
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee can you hear me okay
good morning
good morning let me see if i can share
my video as well
there you go
um
good morning again and um thank you for
the opportunity to speak in front of you
today
i am speaking in opposition to this bill
representative telersky is correct that
we have
heard this bill in the past as well
and we have opposed that in the past as
well i also shared with the committee a
handout that i wanted to discuss did
everyone see that from me
it would have been
a little earlier this morning and but i
can look to see if i can share my screen
let me just see
if you bear with me for just a second
i've got too many screens open let's see
there we go can you see that okay
we
cannot let me try this
about now
yes okay
it's coming there you go yeah perfect so
i think it's important to really take a
look at the data and the statistics um
to really have a frame of reference when
we're speaking about this bill you can
see the last seven calendar years
related to administrative actions taken
by the director oh and i'm sorry i'm
gonna back up for the record my name is
elizabeth bialecki director of motor
vehicles representing the dmv
um so you can see that really the
majority of the requests that we are
getting are coming from law enforcement
followed closely by medical
professionals
and very few requests that we receive
are actually requests by family members
but it's also important to note that of
those that are received from family
members
the significant percentage of them were
actually taking immediate action so let
me just speak really briefly about the
options that we have depending on the
circumstances that are described in the
letter
we can either bring the individual in
for re-exam
meaning we will do a full vision test
we'll do a knowledge test and finally if
those two are passed we'll take the
individual out for a road test
we can bring them in for a hearing and
that will be likely medical hearing
if the
circumstances described
give us an indication of maybe medical
issues and in that case they'll have an
administrative hearing where they'll
have to prove that they are medically
fit to continue to drive
but in many instances for example 16 out
of the 20 that we received during 2020
we take immediate action and we
typically take that action on under rsa
263 59 which is
suspension foreign competency or
improper driving what that means is the
circumstances that are being described
to us are significant enough where we
decide to take the individual's license
right away because there's immediate
danger for them to continue to be
driving
i will tell you also that with any of
these administrative actions we handle
them with a lot of care especially the
ones that are coming in from the family
member my assistants will actually just
call and discuss the circumstances with
the family member and let them know that
their identity will not be kept
confidential so that if the individual
who is being
retested brought in for a hearing or
whose license is being immediately
suspended asks the question we have to
share with them who's reported them in
instances where the family member has
reservations about doing that they do
have other options meaning
they can
reach out to their local law enforcement
and request that maybe they review
the
um the driving record of the individual
to see if it rises to a request that can
be put into us
or reach out to a family to a family
physician or a medical provider and as
you can see again from the numbers that
i provided to you the majority of those
requests are coming from those
we again take these requests very
seriously and evaluate the circumstances
i know that representative gay is
looking for us to research the driving
ability and we usually do but there are
many of these circumstances where um
these individuals already are not
driving a whole lot so their motor
vehicle driving history might be perfect
they might not have any fender benders
they might not have any violations they
might actually have
a really good driving history and
there's no indication from looking at
that that there are any issues
we also know that family members really
know um
the driving abilities of their um of
their family member the best so we do
take um we we put a lot of weight on the
requests that are received by us
so again
there aren't that many there are other
options for family members that are not
feeling comfortable putting
a request in
and for those reasons i would
respectfully ask that you itl the bill
and thank you for your time and
attention i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you director any questions from
the committee
chief representative representative
sykes
thank you mr chairman uh
representative uh director belecki thank
you for taking my question um
do you have any statistics on the
numbers of
as free as
the issue brought forward by this bill
what i might call malicious reports
um i don't representative sykes um
because we really
the fact that we always make personal
contact with the reporting party we kind
of gauge as to whether they have an idea
is it is it really a true request is
someone having um if you know is are the
circumstances different than what
they're describing so i think the fact
that we're making personal contact we're
asking them to put in the request and
writing
sign it as well i think that puts a lot
of weight in on that process as well so
they really think about the
circumstances and they really think
about the consequences of putting in
that request
thank you director
uh chair recognizes representative hill
uh yes thank you mr chairman and thank
you director for
coming and speaking with us
um i want to publicly thank you you
helped me in this situation uh just in
the last year with uh
with a mother-in-law driving um
my question today is um is in relation
to those three categories you just gave
us uh the law enforcement the medical
professional and family
i don't see anything on there from
the neighbor that watches
the
elderly driver
backing out and
taking out trash cans every day
is that an option is there is there
something that allows uh
just a friendly observer from
saying that uh this person shouldn't be
driving any longer
thank you for the question i'm happy
that we were able to assist in your
personal situation as well um no the
answer to that question is no if there
is a neighbor or a bystander or someone
who's not related their option would be
to report it to the local law
enforcement and allow them to take it
from there but we would not um take any
action based on we on a report from
someone who's not related
thank you uh follow a quick follow-up
follow up um
this is um a tremendously difficult uh
procedure i i wouldn't have anticipated
it um and i'm sure i'll be one of those
as well that uh is drag kicking and
screaming but it is um
it's important to me that the that the
department um not handle things as
as clinically um i i don't know if
there's an easier way and i'm i'm hoping
the director has some suggestions
perhaps of
rather than having someone come in and
and
walking out without their license um
is there
is there any other procedure that takes
place across the country that you're
aware of that that may be
less clinical
i can tell you that um
again we have a very
we have a process that very detailed um
i personally review every single one of
them i don't delegate this at this
authority to anybody else so all of
those in 2020 the 267 law enforcement
requests the 147 medical and family i
sign off on every single one of them
oftentimes i will request additional
information
specifically when it's from law
enforcement if i see multiple accidents
on someone's records i will
request the accident reports and
personally review all of them
i really don't take this
this task very lightly because i know
that i'm really taking away someone's
driving
privileges at the end of the road so
this is a task that
again i carefully review myself
um
i think if we looked at what the process
is somewhere else you probably would
find that is it is a bit more automated
than it is in new hampshire so i'm
really proud of the fact that we are
able to really
carefully review the circumstances and
not just look at this as another process
but really see the people that are
behind the letters that we are receiving
thank you thanks my question
thank you director thank you
representative hill that is the quickest
follow-up i think i can remember
next up chair recognizes representative
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
director barack belecki for your
testimony and answering my question here
you kind of partially answered it about
you eventually sign off but my i guess
my initial question is when someone
makes a report whether whether it's a
family member or medical professional
law enforcement who's kind of like the
first person who handles it at the dmv
and how does it get processed from there
before it gets down eventually to you
for the sign off sure um so it actually
comes those type of requests come to the
office of the director um i've got a
couple employees that actually gather
that or intake all of that information
and oftentimes they kind of know what my
process is so they see that it's an
incomplete request they will reach out
and
follow up for some information
we have a lot of information available
throughout our system as well so
oftentimes
they will actually
prepare for me the motor vehicle driving
history any related accident reports or
anything else that is within our system
that would help me make the
determination
we also work very closely with poop g
and i'm very lucky to have sergeant case
which i know you've met him in his
testimony at times as well he kind of
takes the prosecution approach to a lot
of these meaning that if we bring
someone in for a hearing he'll represent
the dmv to present
our position on some of these as well
so if the circumstances are a little
different and i'm struggling with what
decision i want to make oftentimes i'll
bring him in and ask for his advice on
some of these as well um so again just a
quick intake process to gather any
supporting documents that would help
make the decision and then my careful
review and sometimes the assistance of
law enforcement did i have any questions
does that answer your question
representative gorski uh it does a
little bit but can i have a follow-up mr
chairman
hello uh so basically the the people who
are taking the intake you mentioned the
first two are they just in taking
information
or are they looking at it to kind of do
some type of assessment
they really just are taking the
information kind of putting the whole
packet together where the request is
coming from any supporting documentation
and kind of adding anything else to
create a whole
case for me based on which i can make a
decision
great thank you doc thank you director
blecky let me see one more
representative
thank you mr chair
and thank you uh commissioner blacky i i
appreciate you coming today and
giving all this great information
i'm interested to know
what is about the average time between
a report
and the conclusion of the reporting
period
we turn these around pretty quickly so
depending on how quickly
my staff really processes these daily um
so depending on how quickly they can
gather any supporting documentation we
really within two three maybe two to
three business days have a decision that
being said
if it's a hearing we pass it on to the
hearing queue so the individual will be
scheduled for a hearing probably within
15 business day or so
if it's a re-exam
we pass it on to our licensing bureau
and they'll reach out and schedule
them to come in for a re-exam so that
could take a week or two depending on
availability of appointments if it's an
immediate suspension we will send out a
letter that gives the individual five
business days before their license goes
under suspension
so we allow that mail time
um to be um so that the individual is
not driving with a suspended license
thank you for that and so when a person
is reported
uh is there any kind of like
probation or that they should not be
driving until this is all figured out
um no thank you for the question um they
really may continue to drive until
again depending on the action if it's
re-exam they continue to have the
ability to drive unless they fail three
times as representative gay mentioned if
they fail their
exams for example knowledge test if they
fail it three times um that will be a
suspension of their license
if they at at a hearing if they come in
for a hearing at the conclusion of the
hearing they can still drive home and
there'll be a hearing report that is
issued within usually 20 days of the
hearing in which a decision will be made
so they still have some more time on the
quickest suspension is again with the
immediate suspension
and that will be within five days of us
making that decision
to allow us to give them time to be
okay thank notified and just one other
quick very quickly yes thank you okay um
and so and also how do you deal with uh
some of these folks who may be very
belligerent during the whole
process um
what if they don't want to come in and
be tested or you know they
yeah thank you for that
honestly we don't see a whole lot of
that i think these individuals if it's a
family member that reports them they
kind of know it's coming if it's a
medical provider that reports them they
typically have a conversation with them
before they um send us the letter so
again they're kind of expecting it and
oftentimes people just don't show up
we'll schedule them for a retest to come
in for a knowledge test and then they
they don't show up so again we'll give
them three chances if they don't show up
once we'll reschedule them for the test
again if they don't show up the second
time they get a third try and three
strikes and that's when we will take um
the action to suspend them as well so
um we don't see a lot of them that
really
are
showing their emotions while going
through the process
thank you very much thank you
thanks see no other questions from
the committee do have president obama i
don't see anybody on the queue on my end
oh representative
excuse me thank you mr chair i received
a message that the person in the waiting
room who's calling out on the phone
doesn't know how to raise her hand it's
representative nutter of them
okay i see a phone number but it's not
complete
i can read it to you
she texted it to me our technician might
be able to uh figure out how to package
it
yes yes
thank you
know how to m.u
joe hill
brad do you know how to oh she's just a
musician
good morning
thank you this is
uh representative francis another upbeam
nashwing new hampshire hillsboro 33
and i just wanted to speak briefly in
favor okay
representative can i get you to start
over i just need you your name we
couldn't hear you
i'm sorry okay um francis with an e
nutter
tyson upcamp
okay thank you
okay um
uh briefly i want to speak out in favor
of this bill with the amendment
um
i had two elderly relatives
who we you know
difficult to get the car keys away from
them when they were past
their driving prime shall we say and i
notice a very delicate
matter among family members and any help
that family members can be
given to take the correct
and legal actions
when people are past their best ability
to drive i think is very important
thank you for hearing my testimony today
thank you very much any questions
seeing none thank you again
okay
now i don't see any other hands of
thecube
thank you everybody i'm going to close
the public hearing on house bill 515
just give us a couple of minutes to
reset please and we'll move right into
it
six
okay
the public hearing up on house bill 386
an act relative to the operation of
certain watercraft on i hope i'm saying
this right we'll watch a pocket pond
plant sponsors representative sykes so
whenever you're already represented you
have the floor
thank you mr chairman um
so this bill is uh came about as as a
result of a
constituent request
and um
i would also tell you that for ease of
um conversation that this pond is also
known locally
as meter ponds so that's a little easier
to get out than the actual official name
meter m-e-a-d-e
okay thank you yeah it's a little easier
um
so
the story goes like this so we have i
have um
some folks who
are
have great difficulty paddling they have
no upper body strength
remaining
one of those persons actually has a
handicapped plate as well
and but they also know that the state of
new hampshire fish and game department
regularly stocks meter pond with trout
and so and they love to go trout fishing
it is already on the list for
prohibiting any type of motorized
transport on the pond which is not an
uncommon thing in new hampshire
but they have great difficulty paddling
so they
are not able to enjoy
this really great pond that's close to
their home
um the criteria under which
ponds are chosen to be protected in this
way
according to the fish and game and the
also
the department of safety's
they have shared responsibilities for
this
um
are that a pond needs to be if it's
under 10 acres
and under
i forget the depths quite frankly but
under a certain depth then
propeller driven
you know motor boats etc are prohibited
and that's to protect
the the pond and that's not an
unreasonable situation
by the way this pond is in the white
mountain national forest as well
the state does have a list of exceptions
the bill
the the original authorization for
prohibiting pods has a a long list of
exceptions
so i did some research spoke to fish and
game
spoke to the department of safety
tried to ask them
was
how do how did these these laws
treat fairly
handicapped individuals
and they really didn't have a good
answer the answer was well you know
that's really a good idea we should
probably think about doing something
uh the thinking about doing something
has not resulted in any action however
through rules or through legislation i
also learned in my research that
meteopond
while it's on the list of prohibited
to motors
is over 10 acres and is over the not not
in its entirety of course but um is over
the
depth where it would be typically
uh prohibited
i did ask why that the pond was on that
list and did not receive
any clarity from either of the
departments it's just what's always been
on the list
i have a problem with that i i think
that we should be making recreational
opportunities available on an equal
basis to handicapped individuals
nothing in the
the
stated reasons for keeping this pond
listed
in terms of criteria are met and so i
felt that the only possible solution was
legislatively and this bill would add
meter ponds specifically
to
be allowed to use the smallest
trolling electric trolling motor only
that's commercially available
and only if one of the persons operating
the the canoe which is typical
has a handicap plate as well and that's
the bill
and i'd be happy to take any questions
yeah thank you uh
representative did you say the pond is
larger than 10 acres
yes i went on the usgs map and
did scaled it out and it is over 10
acres
and i obviously had to do some
conversion maybe my
hopefully my math was right
thank you um
representative hill
uh yes thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking my question representative
are there any um ada
accessibility requirements for things
like this
um not specific to the the inability to
use motorized
conveyances
there may be otherwise
i didn't delve into it carefully enough
to know
but i do know that specific to not being
able to use a motorized
method of conveyance there is no
handicapped uh exception
thank you
uh i have one more question
representative sykes
i may get the answer but i don't
recognize the names uh you said you
dealt with the fish and game
department
usually when there's legislation before
then the commission does take a gathered
opinion do you know if they've
determined the opinion
oh you know
i went looking for my notes honestly
this most of those discussions happened
more than seven months ago
um just because this has been a
the this first came to my attention
after the end of the legislative season
in private prior session and so
i kept trying to talk to people that uh
and
i don't remember i apologized it was
captain um there was a captain from
the department of safety and then
someone from fish and game as well uh i
mean are they on your witness list well
i
perhaps will get the answer i i don't
recognize them i just figured that i
figured i'd ask first so yeah i'm sorry
i should have uh prepped a little better
for this um
the there was something that you asked
that question and there was something
else i was going to add and now i've
forgotten maybe it'll come back
representative phil is your hand still
up or did you have another question
okay thank you representative wesley
thank you mr chairman and and thank you
representative spike sykes to take my uh
question i just want to get some clarity
i'm just getting confused a little bit
um
are you saying that no motor
can be used over 55 pounds at all
are you saying
it can only be used if someone in the
boat has a handicap plate
both so
they are restricted to a specific type
of moto motor which is the again the
smallest commercially available electric
trolling motor for anybody
for any no yes that's that's the only
type of motor and only if they have a
handicapped plate and that's what thank
you for that question because it
reminded me that the point of those two
restrictions particularly the
handicapped plate one was a
a matter of fairness quite obviously but
also would limit the numbers of people
who are using these pods because we do
want to protect the resource
so so so uh follow-up is the channel
so just to get clarity for me maybe it's
just me my
maybe my pole is showing me again i
don't know um
it's so
you're saying that
that a 55
pound motor
can be used on the pond
as long as
one of the people who are in the boat
has a handicap plate correct
thank you
senator pickering
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
um
in the past before this committee um
there's been an issue when a
when a written suggested law
is too specific and i just wondered if
you could help me understand
why there isn't
why doesn't doesn't this fit into any
bigger category as far as the
distinction between petroleum power
versus
electric
and as far as sizes it sounds to me like
you ran into a problem but then the
solution seems to be awfully specific so
could you address that for me please
sure um i chose this methodology because
if you look at the list of other ponds
um i think there's more than 20 of them
that are accepted out from the general
requirement
and every one of them has a different
explanation for the reason for their
being excluded
and i chose this methodology to go back
to representative dorsey's point
question was i very much want to limit
the amount of people who will be using
that pond because it's a very
environmentally sensitive
area
um it's in the
well the pond spreads around several
towns but it's up in the thornton
warren
basically grafton county uh and in the
national forest so
that that's the reason for the very the
incredible specificity
of the requirements
thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
representative sykes
um
you're helping mr turtle and
representative o'hare i see no
hands raised in the queue
that one just went up okay
yeah that's one of the persons i spoke
to yep thank you
good morning mr chair are you able to
hear me
good morning sir
thank you my name is tim dunleavy and
i'm captain with the new hampshire state
police marine patrol unit
and i i thank you for taking my
testimony this morning
honourable members of the transportation
committee the department of safety and
marine patrol
opposes this bill
and i will qualify my statements by
saying in no
way are we looking to
not be sensitive to the needs of those
who have uh intellectual or physical
challenges in our state to be able to
use our public waters
the the issue here with
watch apoca ponder meter pond is we like
to to use with the locals especially
is that rsa 270 29
supersedes all the
authority of the commissioner of safety
to adopt regulations
and that that statute has prohibited the
use of any mechanical power
on any body of water within the white
mountain national forest
and that statute further goes for goes
forward to
um
accept several bodies of water that you
as the legislature
acknowledged should be made available to
uh motorboats stinson lake for example
the percy ponds and stark
kimball pond and chatham and long pond
which is nearby to meter pond and benton
those have
easy public access by vehicle quite
frankly and i suspect that's why the
legislature exempted them
meter pond
if you look at the fish and game
maps that they have for fishing on their
website lists meter pond as a walk-in
remote site although i can tell you
unfortunately i investigated a drowning
there years ago and and there is a a
rough uh
road or path into the pond
um
representative spike uh sykes speaks to
our conversation and how various
restrictions exist around the state for
these
uh
power boats
outside of the national forest uh due to
the statutes
those bodies of water over 10 acres in
size
are considered public waters and
therefore fall into the jurisdiction of
the state
and statute allows through the public
hearing process for
a petition to be submitted by the
general public to change or to create
restrictions
on our public waters
so representative sykes is very uh
correct when he says that there are 20
or so bodies of water that have these
unique
restrictions or exemptions
and and that has been established
through the petition process where where
folks uh seek a change
so
with that that's a little history of how
these uh restrictions come to be
in in this case this restriction is by
statute
and it is for the protection of a lot of
our remote smaller ponds uh in the
national forest
meter pond is a 28-acre pond with an
average depth of about 10 feet
and it is a popular trout fishing
location
from an enforcement perspective our
concern is is if we encounter
someone out there with an electric motor
the ability sometimes to track down
uh that that plate due to the remoteness
of this pond may find the vehicle in
some some other
uh
location significantly further away from
the pond um and so uh
under these circumstances and and
because of the existing restrictions uh
we reflect respectfully ask that this be
found in expedia to legislate i'm happy
to answer any questions
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
crawford
thank you mr chair could you just uh
excuse me thank you um captain
uh
emily uh could you just repeat the rsa
frame it's 270
it is uh 270
standby
270 colon 29 operation prohibited
it's a relatively brief statute that if
you'd like me to read i'd be happy to do
so no i just needed the number thank you
so much
representative
thank you mr chairman i'll be very brief
um i just have the same question what
what do we have for
access
via ada requirements for
public ponds in new hampshire
i can't speak specifically as as fish
and game is the agency that oversees
public access and boat launches but what
i am familiar with is that when federal
funds are used to create public access
um then then certainly ada uh compliance
must be uh
factored into that
oftentimes and i know there are numerous
bodies of water around the state where
where ada compliant fishing piers uh
shoreline fishing piers are part of that
that access and development
um and we and and there are examples
where our public hearing process
has opened up bodies of water to
mechanical power for those
with with challenges
but those bodies of waterfall outside
the national forest and and have been
restrictions have been changed due to
that that public input and the public
hearing process
in this case meter pond is is already
covered by a statute um
where where obviously that would trump
any ability of the department to to
create an exception
and the fact that it's in the national
forest with all our other
restricted smaller bodies of water
thank you
questions
seeing none thank you very much
thank you for your time
all right let me see no other hands up
so i will close the public hearing on
house bill 380
6.
um
10 o'clock 100.
that was very sexy
this
so this is interesting
i can introduce
okay i'm going to open the public
hearing
hospital 100.
because i don't have a vice chair today
i'm not going to actually
um introduce it myself so representative
aaron is going to do it for us thank you
thank you mr chair i am
going to introduce this bill house bill
100 which is relative to driving on the
left of an unbroken painted line
and this bill
seeks an exemption to the prohibition on
crossing unbroken painted center lines
while driving on any way
thank you very much
any questions
seeing none i'll just i'll remind you
i'll bring everybody up to speed on this
this was a bill that was put in
uh last term by at the time
representative flanagan
with just issues that had happened um
actually people get excited for crossing
the unbroken painted line
in circumstances where they had no
choice
so i looked at it as just a host keeping
the bill and just a common sense built
it was his experience that he'd actually
been taking it if i remember correctly
for
making maneuver across the painted line
but he had no choice to because of the
vehicle parked on the side of the road
or at the time i think there was also uh
emergency equipment et cetera et cetera
so
uh there is a simple bill that's why you
see it again again this did pass last
year and it was also one of those bills
that made it to the senate but did not
rise to the level of importance enough
to make it to one of their on the bus
bills so it has been reintroduced
any questions from the committee
that's not delayed
thank you mr chair can you just and i
don't know if even you remember going
back to the first time this was
introduced
we had a problem with it and then it was
amended again
is it
the amendment that finally got us to
pass it last year was it just clarifying
the move over law in there
you know that's a great question and
that is taxing my memory i know i'm
sorry no that's okay it's good i'm gonna
look into it um we'll get the answers on
that before we try to execute this thing
thanks
uh see representative aaron yes i uh
thank you mr chair i just wanted to
bring to your attention
um
that william lambert from the new
hampshire d.o.t
had registered to testify on this bill
but had inadvertently checked that he
opposed uh this bill but actually he
doesn't
he is in favor of it so i just wanted to
bring that to your attention thank you
it was on my list of things to do okay
now it's off
representative
thank you mr chairman the question is
for you maybe you can help me with
memory as well when you're looking at
the last version that we passed i i
can't recall whether it called out an
exception just for bicycles and
non-motorized pedestrians etc i thought
the original bill
was you could do that under you know if
you needed to
under
safe you know it was a safe operation
i'm i'm a little concerned are we
hearing from any of the bicyclists
bicycling community about this
particular bill
um
just
i i i'm sure they might have an opinion
i just wondered if they're signed up
um
we'll see i don't they don't recognize
themselves obviously at this point who
they represent uh i
just heard representative aaron um
that mr lambert from dot is in favor of
this bill and i have to be honest with
you my memory is not as good as it used
to be in terms of the changes last year
all i can say is that we'll look into it
before
thank you thank you for that mr chairman
i see representative gorski
thank you mr chairman just a quick
question uh what's the chapman act
i don't remember you really gotta put me
on the spot on this one don't you again
this was a bill put it by a former
representative
okay it's returned as a currency more or
less okay because it did actually pass
and uh we just wanted it to pass again
thank you all right see no other
questions i'll get myself off the hot
seat
uh let's see who
is
see anybody else queued up
to speak
i do not either
nobody else pre-signed up so with that
again we'll get the answers that we need
before we attempt to execute this good
questions i'll close the public hearing
on house bill 100.
it looks like we gained a little time
so we'll be doing a house bill 461 at 10
30. yeah like instead of florida's
small breaks we'll see you back then
mr chair
would you like me to mute your room
while you guys are
on visa
excuse me
would you like me to meet the room when
you guys are on recess i know that was
an issue last time yes
yes please
okay
yeah and if i need to get to the screen
i can i can unmute it from here
okay
thank you
[Music]
sound check can you hear me are we live
okay thank
you all right welcome back everybody i'm
going to open up the public hearing on
house bill 461
an act relative to motorcycle observably
lamping
and adding the new hampshire
motorcyclist rights organization to the
traffic safety commission uh client
sponsors
speaker packard
who couldn't make it this morning so
i'll have representative smith
speaker smith introduce the bill
thank you mr chair members of the
committee i'm representative stephen
smith sullivan county district 11
acworth charlestown goshen langer
webster and washington
this bill does two things
one it adds the new hampshire motorcycle
rights organization to the traffic
safety commission the traffic safety
commission is a group of
people who represent various industries
and transportation vehicles school bus
drivers and new hampshire motor
transport association
the department of safety and a variety
of other people so that when there are
traffic safety issues all the
stakeholders are in the room this would
add the new hampshire motorcycle rights
organization to that and that's
appropriate they are the leading force
in new hampshire for investigating
motorcycle issues safety issues and in
addition they provide a great motorcycle
safety class that's offered by many
people so it's appropriate for them to
have a seat at the table
the second thing that it does is uh one
of our statutes doesn't let you have
more than three lights on the front of a
motorcycle
now there are a lot of bikes that have
dual headlights and then for safety you
also want the lights that are on the
bars down by the roads so they can see
if there's a raccoon laying in the road
easier it gives you a more close-up view
so if you have one on each side and the
bike came from the factory once your
headlights steps four
and while the national highway traffic
safety administration says this is a
good thing to do and many bikes actually
come from the factory with this lighting
installed they're illegal in new
hampshire so and consider the second
part of the build a clean up measure so
that we are not conflicting with federal
regulations
and that is the bill thank you mr
chairman
thank you representative any questions
from this video
it's being done thank you again
i want to get two people signed up to
testify let's see if we can find them
um the chair would recognize tracy
borovage
representing the new hampshire
motorcyclist rights organization
come over there
i see you on thecube okay
i'm here
good morning we can hear you now
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for your time
this morning
uh i am tracy borvaj i'm the president
of new hampshire motorcycle rights
organization
and i am here to respectfully request
that you support this bill hb 461.
as representative smith said
motorcyclists have never been
representative on this commission
in the past
and as a big part of the roadway users
in new hampshire we feel that
motorcyclists should have a voice
last session
we came before the same commission i
mean before the same committee
requesting to be put on this commission
the the transportation committee last
session did vote to put us on
the full house voted to put us on and
what happened in all the chaos
we did not make or the bill did not make
it to the senate to be voted uh so we're
here again unfortunately
doing it all over um for those of you
who do not know nhmr i just want to take
a quick few minutes because i don't want
to waste anybody's time
just to tell you a little bit about what
we do
we came up with a ride smart program i
know it's a little bit hard for all of
you to see it
but it represents a lot of what new
hampshire motorcycle rights does
writing smart safely maturely aware
respectfully and trained in 2019 we took
this and we went and met with captain
haynes of the new hampshire state police
and we started a motorcycle task force
we then partnered with new hampshire
automobile dealers association the
office of highway safety
triple a and i i heart media in the
writer's education program and went
further with it and came up with a
hashtag live free ride smart program so
we've now gone statewide we now have
monies funded from the 402 funds and
nitsa
and we now have psas out there for
writing smart and riding safely so we
have a big voice something that
motorcyclists have never had in this
state on how to ride safely how to write
smart we believe that that making smart
and knowledgeable
riders make smarter riders and better
riders so we're doing a lot of things
that motorcyclists have never done in
this state so being part of this
commission we feel like would be a very
good thing for the rest of the safety
commission the rest of the roadway users
and a very important thing for
motorcyclists so again i respectfully
request that you support this bill and
thank you for your time
thank you
any questions from the committee
i see representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman um i said one
quick question i'm going to safely
assume you
drive a car also
okay and cat follow up real quick mr
chairman
follow-up
okay do you see any hazard
for auto drivers when there's four
headlights coming towards them
so did he i and i i had just it's kind
of echoey did you say do i see any
hazard with four headlights coming at a
car from a motorcycle yeah for a vision
or anything standpoint
i i i would say no i think one as a
motorcyclist and and also having cars i
think for for us
motorcycles need to be
visually seen and i and i don't think
that there's a problem with having
more
more light you know
i agree thank you
any other questions from the committee
seeing nuns thank you very much thank
you thank you for your time
and next chair recognizes
dan bennett from the new hampshire auto
dealers association
yes good morning mr chairman can you
hear me
good morning
okay good morning
uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak with you all this morning um
i do wish that we were uh in the back of
room 203 but it is what it is so i hope
to see you all there soon uh my name is
dan bennett i'm with the new hampshire
auto dealers association
we represent car truck motorcycle
snowmobile dealers um across the state
so we are here in support of um hb 461
as we were on this bill uh dealing with
motorcycle lamping as well as the
traffic safety commission uh both bills
which easily passed last year we are in
support of the discussion on auxiliary
lamping started between ourselves and
department of safety troop g uh about a
year and a half ago when we realized
either through aftermarket lamping or
straight from the manufacturer vehicles
were in violation of our safety wall so
auxiliary lamping allows greater
visibility for both the rider as well as
oncoming traffic and unfortunately the
current law doesn't allow more than
three
because a motorcycle is lumped in with
the definition of motor vehicle
it really applies to cars it doesn't
apply to bikes um
when bikes add lights they add them in
even numbers they don't add them in odd
numbers they're done in pairs it's done
on the left and right of the fork a left
and right of the foot peg
hanging down uh from the two main lamps
the way um deputy speaker smith
mentioned so for any of you all i know i
sent something around to the committee
yesterday
and hopefully you all received it i did
not i did not have it in color here but
from the pictures that i sent to you all
you can see the various types of lamping
that folks do
to enhance their um their visibility
and to respond to representative
o'hara's question um
these are not blinding led light strips
that would be on the hood of a jeep or a
truck so uh this is not something that
would heavily interfere um and be
blinding to oncoming traffic so there
are no
in our opinion there are no and i think
that hopefully the department of safety
would echo that as well there's no um
concerns there because they were
supportive of this effort last year as
well so
um
that's it for for the lamping issue the
next thing i'll talk about is the
traffic safety commission um nhada is a
member of the traffic safety commission
and we've sat on it i have for a number
of years we wholeheartedly support
having nhmro become a member a great
deal of our
discussions
uh are around the accidents of
motorcycles accidents injuries and
unfortunate deaths
so having their voice be part of how can
we make the roadways safer especially
for for bikes and riders um our great
motorcycle tourist destination state um
having their voice uh on this commission
we think would be um incredibly
beneficial so um
thank you for hopefully your support on
this bill which um i think based on its
success last year hopefully is a pretty
easy one for you all
and um if there are any questions i'd be
glad to try and handle them
thank you i do see one question
representative hill
thank you mr chairman uh and thank you
for taking my question
i um i just had one is it uh is it your
uh contention that this bill would be
for the visibility of the
motorcycle operator or
the visibility of the motorcycle by the
traveling public
thank you for the question
representative hill
it's both um
it's both for the rider um you know i
think if you think about a a single
headlamp uh versus a headlamp and then
two mounted lower uh you know on about a
two to three inch spindle and then two
more down by their feet it's really just
going to enhance that
that field of vision for both oncoming
and the riders themselves so i'm not
sure if you all have the um
and hopefully you do have the images
that i sent over yesterday morning but i
think it makes it pretty clear um how it
will help both
the questions from the committee
thank you
yes i just promoted them
good morning mr chairman good morning
i i appreciate your time and thank you
committee members i apologize i'm still
learning the signing procedure so
hopefully i have this down and uh i will
have to raise my hand next time i just
sign in uh like normal uh i am a
lieutenant player i'm the troop
commander from troop g and we work very
closely with the division of motor
vehicles and uh oftentimes we work very
closely with new hampshire automobile
dealers association as well i'm here
representing the department of safety
today and we have worked with the new
hampshire honorable dealers in regards
to this bill this was something that
they brought to our attention where
there was a concern where motorcycles uh
in particular they have one headlight
and then oftentimes they come from the
manufacture you see it especially with
harley davidsons where there's two
auxiliary allowed two auxiliary lights
mounted to the left or right of the
headlight this precludes motorcycles
from being able to have additional
auxiliary lamps down low that can help
light the uh the sides of the roadways
so
it's prohibited that they can't
necessarily see off to the sides where
there might be a small animal that's
going to dart out in front of them uh so
we worked with nhad to help craft the
language of this bill to add four
auxiliary lights specifically for the
purposes of motorcycles to help the uh
improve driver safety uh as a secondary
feature obviously it does help
motorcycles be seen by oncoming drivers
and
the department safety supports this bill
thank you sir
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
thank you very much
representative sites unless they're
trying to do this now but
there's a possibility if things go well
this afternoon perhaps we might be able
to get this uh
part of our uh executive session just
figured i could throw that out there
so
that being said uh
our next hearing
will be at 11 o'clock house bill 628 and
we'll see all that thank you
exercise good job getting your exercise
you're getting your exercise
can anybody hear me
okay thank you
uh let's open the public hearing on
house bill 628 fn
an act relative to maximum vehicle speed
limitations
uh representative
is the prime sponsor
thank you mr chairman
uh afternoon no good morning
i'm great i'm great
i
i wanted to thank mr chairman and
distinguished members of the committee
i'm here to introduce and ask for
support of hb 628 which seeks to
increase the speed limit on certain new
hampshire roads
this bill is a result of a constituent
request the bill seeks to
increase the speeds on roads currently
55 miles an hour to 60 miles an hour and
mile an hour roads to 70 miles an hour
and a few sections of road currently uh
70 miles an hour to 75.
so just a five mile an hour increase on
uh
those roads
if you
excuse me uh if you have driven on uh
highways 90 uh 101 and 93 you're all
already fully aware that the flow of
traffic is is already 70 miles an hour
and sometimes even 75 because motorists
naturally find a come comfortable speed
for the road over time unless it's
artificially
uh
lowered
by
speed limits that are strictly enforced
i believe that we should be um not be
sending out our officers to enforce uh
speed which is
significantly lower than most motorists
find to be comfortable for the road
that would increase
speed differentials
between those driving at a comfortable
speed
for the road and those driving to avoid
the long arm of the law
as steven johnson professor of
industrial engineering with mac
blackwell national rural
transportation study center noted on a
study regarding speed differential
ramifications
he quote we found that speed variations
and vehicle interactions have a direct
impact on highway safety unquote while
accidents at higher speeds
increase the likelihood of serious
injury in the crash i suggest that we
already have those conditions on the
ground
now where people are
driving the comfortable speed and um
those speed limits are not aligned uh
and so i hope that you'll support the
this uh change of speed limits to the
current flow
uh to more accurately reflect the
current flow of traffic on these roads
so
that we encourage everyone to move at
the same speed
if
such a change needs to be worked into a
transportation plan and that's the
effective date of such legislation needs
to be pushed out to accommodate that i
would support uh such an amendment
uh thank you and i will try to answer
any questions you might have
representative um
thank you mr chair and thank you uh
representative yapella for presenting
this today
my question is if you are to
if we are to raise the speed limits
then
how do you believe that will affect uh
the
traffic around work zone areas because
then those speed limits also are raised
because
i believe you have to slow down a
certain amount
around those speed limit around those
work areas but it would essentially
raise
the speed limit around those areas as
well
thank you for the question
i
am not
uh
i'm not i think the best person to
answer that question the ramifications
of what speed um
is near
workers or highway workers
i've seen definitely multiple
speed speeds from 25 miles an hour next
to
next to workers to you know 55 miles an
hour next to workers so i'm not
sure that
what the ramifications are like how far
away from the
people
driving that they need to be for
increased speed
et cetera et cetera i'm not
sure of the ramifications of that so i'm
not sure i am the best person to answer
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
i'm just curious if um
in any of your research on this issue
if you raise the
speed limit by five miles per hour to
perhaps
match up with what you're calling a
comfortable driving speed that people
are doing anyway
what's to prevent people from then going
another five miles per hour over because
they see it as that that window of what
is a comfortable flow of traffic which
would potentially put people at 80 miles
an hour in the 75 mile per hour zone
thank you for the question
i think that there are some people that
just want to push the
the limits of what they can get away
with and that there are other people
that just drive
at a speed that is
um comfortable for the for the road and
the terrain
and
my my uh suggestion is that
that the current speed limit is even
below what people find comfortable not
um necessarily uh
the people that are always trying to
push the boundaries those people are are
going to be pushing the boundaries no
matter what speed limit you put
but thank you for the question
what are the questions from the
committee
seeing them thank you representative
she recognizes
gary abbott representing the associated
general contractors of new hampshire
neutral
on the bill
sorry mr bear what name did you say
uh gary abbott
thank you chairman walsh and committee
members for the record my name's gary
abbott i'm the executive vice president
of the associated general contractors of
new hampshire
i know i sent the committee a letter
yesterday
regarding this issue
we are neutral on the bill we would
leave it up to the department of safety
safety wise of whether increasing the
speed limits is the right thing to do
our concern comes out of the unintended
consequences
relating to a different statute
statute 265 colon 60 deals with
kind of safety in the work zone and
highway workers
that are working on highways
right now that work zone has language
that says the reduction would be 10
miles an hour or more
we know in in the practical world that
d.o.t tries to design it to 10 miles an
hour under the speed limit
our concern comes over highway worker
safety and people in the roadways
and so i did attach to that position
paper some language that if you were to
pass this bill
we do not really want any changes in the
speed limits so
for anything i added language that would
allow that any highways 55 miles an hour
or over
instead of seeing a 10 mile an hour
reduction would see a 15.
so that's really where uh our group
i brought it up to the contractors i
represent large commercial contractors
who work on the highways and buildings
and clearly we just don't want to see
any increase in work zone speed limits
so we really looked at the unintended
consequence of changing the speed limits
again we don't have a position on
whether the legislature you know what
speeds are set
but when it comes to
our we're always working with the
department of transportation to try to
make sure our highways are as safe as
possible
but we would like to have that change if
the committee decides to move forward
with the bill and i would end my
testimony and answer any questions you
may have
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
seeing that thank you again thank you
very much chairman
did you
recognize william lambert representing
department of transportation who
proposes the bill
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee
for the record my name is bill lambert
i'm the state traffic engineer for the
new hampshire department of
transportation
in that role i am also
granted the commissioners delegated a
delegated authority
uh for determining state speed zones on
rsa 265 62. i've had that authority
since 2013
prior to that that authority was uh was
granted to each of the the regional
district engineers in our highway
maintenance bureau
i can tell you from that point of time i
probably spent
30 to 40 percent of my
engineering time as state traffic
engineer dealing with concerns about
speed and speed limits um
and i've been uh asked by the institute
of transportation engineers to
participate in a um
developing a a um
i guess a case study collective for best
management practices with regard to
setting speed limits uh i've also been
involved with uh
ashto at the national level uh with
changes to the mutcd regarding speed
limits so
i do deal with speed limits quite a bit
and i did submit written testimony i
believe you folks have that uh on
written by the commissioner
uh i did i don't want to necessarily
read that but i did want to
go through some of the points that i
made in that letter one of the things
that we talk about is state speed zones
so state speed zones
the statutory speed limits are set in
rsa26560
and cities are allowed to alter those
speed statutory speed limits in rsa 265
63 and the commissioner of
transportation is all allowed to alter
those speed limits uh in rsa265 62. in
both cases
any changes are supposed to be based on
an engineering and traffic investigation
uh in the last seven or eight years the
department of transportation has
developed a fairly robust
methodology for determining state speed
zones and very seldomly
do we change do we reduce speed limits
based on
our study or recommendations uh in fact
we've raised several over the last
several years
i can tell you some of our experience at
wakefield route 153 working with and
actually prompted by local police raised
the speed limit from 35 to 45.
that was a road that was probably posted
at 35 in the 60s because of the winding
nature of the road with the premise that
people would slow down when they went
around the curves
studies showed over the years that they
didn't do that
so we work with the police chief and
then the rural sections of 153 increase
the speed limit
the cancer maintenance highway was
another example where we increased the
speed limit from 40 to 50 in the lincoln
livermore area based on speed studies
we also raised a speed limit on route 27
in candia in on route 4a in in wilmot
based on engineering and traffic
investigations all of those came
with pretty broad support from the local
governing body not that they have that
uh authority um but it's it would be uh
disingenuous for us to make those kind
of changes without reaching out to the
local governing body
i also want to point out some places
where we did recommend speed limits be
increased based on the studies that got
rejected uh in reaching out to the local
governing body um
most folks would unders would think that
changing the speed limit is not a good
idea
um
and and we've
tried to convince them otherwise and and
given the reasoning for our recommended
changes but not always with success and
one of those was uh the section of nh120
from claremont to lebanon um which is at
several different speed limits over 18
to 20 miles uh we were recommending
something that was more uniform
but in three of the four communities
that recommendation was not
um accepted although local governing
bodies in two of the towns seemed to
understand the reasoning behind it but
they had some local
i guess pressure uh to not support it
so we didn't make that change in orford
and wentworth on route 25a uh
interestingly
uh the town of wentworth supported
raising the speed limit from 40 to 50
but orford
did not so that remains at the 40 miles
an hour i also talked about some of the
other features related to posted speed
limits and we we have recently completed
or are completing the statewide project
to bring all of our horizontal alignment
warning signs
in line with the current standards and
they're determined based on the
difference between a posted speed limit
and a measured advisory speed and the
measured advisory speed is based on the
deflection of the vehicle as it goes
around a curve
and what we found over the in doing
those projects that there are a number
of speed limits that are probably less
than what the prevailing speed is
uh so that we were taking away curve
warning signs uh when we thought they
they should be
um there should be more well we had a
history of some run off the road crashes
in an example using that wakefield
example
over 12 miles of changing the speed
limit by 10 miles an hour when we went
back and looked at the curve warning
signs we found that we added something
like 200 new assets either chevron's
delineators or curve signs
the other one was the passing zones
where the passing site distances
determined based on the posted speed
limit
and when we raised the speed limit on
the tank 112 in lincoln and livermore
um we ended up closing seven of eight
passing
zones that were on that stretch
because they did not meet the passing
sight distance required for 50 miles an
hour while they did for 40.
and as far as the safety concerns that
this department has for for raising the
speed limits
on the lower speed highways like i
talked about the 153 and wakefield and
some of the other ones
research routinely demonstrates that
changing to the changes to the speed
limit do not
measurably affect the speed of traffic
because people find a comfortable speed
based on the character and condition of
the road
but the research does seem to indicate
that increasing the speed limits on the
higher order highways the ones that were
built for higher speeds with wide sight
distance flat curves and things like
that that the speed does tend to
to go up i know one of the questions
earlier was whether people would get
comfortable with a an increase an
additional five miles per hour increase
if the speed limit increased
i would point that the speed limit north
of concord that went from 65 to 70
several years ago is being considered
for an additional five miles an hour
now and that would kind of be an
indication that that that previous
increase has resulted in a
corresponding increase in the traffic i
can't
i can't
demonstrate that with data we did do
some before and after data or a year or
two after
uh and that was inconclusive but we
haven't gone back and collected that
data since
but the fact that it's being uh
recommended to be or proposed to be
increased another five miles an hour
would be an indication
that there's at least a perception that
speeds have gone up
and while
this the data might be inconclusive as
to what
this might the the speeds might be on
the higher order highways
uh what's not inconclusive is that
higher speeds result in higher
crash severity so with that i'd close my
testimony
the department of transportation would
be opposed to this bill
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
so one question at this point
representative sykes
thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr lambert for taking my question i i
actually have a two-part question if the
chair will indulge me um the first part
is
is my memory correct that i had we had
learned during various testimonies that
the initial
design phase of the interstate highway
system was based on a
a 70 mile per hour safe operating speed
um
i would have to look to make sure my
recollection from my time in the design
office is that most of the interstate
highway
designs were the design speed was 70
miles an hour and as a kid growing up in
the 60s and 70s i remember the posted
speed limit being 70 miles an hour
on the interstate highways until the
energy crisis reduced it to
okay just and then part part two um
within your design work for these types
of things um
and i'll be
frank about this i'm particularly
concerned about route 89 from concord to
the vermont border
there's there's a pretty short there's a
high increase in the elevation i think
it's almost 2000 feet in a very short
time frame
and that means we get wildly different
weather
within that very short time frame
distance frame
and um
the design questions about what speed
limits should be take into consideration
that specificity
yeah i guess i'd ask a follow-up and
thank you for the question i'd ask a
follow-up or clarification is what part
of that
condition would would be considered for
for the design speed is it the elevation
change or or geometry within that
section
well i wasn't thank you uh i'll try and
clarify sometimes my questions could be
a little convoluted um
my particular concern is that the a
couple of factors um
ice on the roadway changes dramatically
from rain to ice on the roadway within
with the elevation increase
the road may in fact be designed fine
for geometry wise but it
doesn't take into consideration that
those types of changes and then of
course there's a whole issue of rain me
becoming snow
and
snow becoming a white out
uh so i
that's where i'm coming from i'm very
very we see a lot of cars off the road
within that uh
well north of warner and
in the you know uh springfield area for
instance
so i think i understand your question
now and and i would say that speed
limits are generally determined based on
ideal traffic and weather conditions so
blue sky daylight dry pavement
when we do the engineering and traffic
investigation it includes a speed study
and the speed study should be
determining what the
prevailing speed is
during ideal weather conditions and the
statute already says that
drivers are expected to adjust their
speed
based on actual conditions the
reasonable improvement standard or
reasonable and safe standard
so if the department has over the last
probably 15 years or so as we've
invested in weather
weather data systems in our the
changeable message signs and things like
that we have identified places like that
section of 89 where we can collect
real-time pavement condition data and
put up messages
for folks to remind them of the road
conditions so that they should slow down
we
we've looked at trying to put a variable
speed limit sign so we'd actually change
the posted speed limit on those roads uh
through the manchester the sale on the
manchester project and the everett
turnpike
but we found that those
systems
communication wise and technology wise
and
cost-wise can be
i guess cost prohibitive to install and
maintain so we tend to be using
i guess our public outreach through the
media and through
our
limited number of changeable method
science when we have those specific
conditions
to remind people that
they should be slowing down during the
weather and we have enough
granularity in our traffic or our
weather data systems to be able to
identify the difference between say i-95
and in the portsmouth area in 93 in
derry and ie9 i-89 in londonderry so we
try to manage that storm by storm in
case by case
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
lambert for taking my question
um
just so i from what i hear you say um
the department is
open to
raising speed limits on certain roadways
when your
investigations studies
recommendations from the local
authorities
direct you to that and the data shows it
but would you agree with me that you're
saying the blanket
um raise of speed limits
statewide um is just not the direct the
best way to go in this circumstance
thank you for the question and i i guess
i would clarify that that the department
has
i guess the legacy system of statewide
speed limits that i've inherited in 2013
would have a a number of speed limits
that i think have been
arbitrarily lowered over the years where
the standard for the engineering and
traffic investigation may not be as
robust as we've had it in the last
ten or
seven or eight years
so that being said i think that legacy
system includes a number of examples
where the speed limit um is much less
than the prevailing speed may be more of
a desired speed and oftentimes the
request that we would get
would be from people that want it to be
less than what they think is reasonable
and safe so that they can start
ticketing people at that at that
reasonable and safe number
um
and that's not really good practice so
um the the ones that i think that would
be real considering increase would be
some of those legacy systems that maybe
were inappropriately reduced in the past
um
that being said i think the data shows
that when you increase speed limits on
those higher order highways the
interstates and the the turnpikes and
those multi-lane divided highways that
were built to a higher standard
does tend to
result in higher speeds and higher
speeds then result in
uh increased
severity of crashes
i guess as an example is when the speed
limit was reached
and i
was hoping that state police would be on
this call
but my understanding when the speed
limit was increased north of concord
from 65 to 70
that there was
a corresponding increase in the
tolerance for doing enforcement and that
really wasn't the intent or the stated
intent
uh if the intent was to stop pulling
people over at 75 before the speed limit
was raised
then arguably that
that 75 would have still been the upper
limit after the speed limit was raised
um i'd like to think that's not the case
but sometimes it has to do with um
enforcing or convicting people in the
courts and what the courts will accept
as
as a um acceptable reasonable and safe
speed and one of the other things about
the interstate speeds it's different in
the statute that people don't understand
is that
the 65 or 70 that's in the statute now
is a per se
speed limit not a prima prime of fascist
speed limit
so by law
any speed over that 75 or 65 or 70
that's in the statute is is a violation
where people could argue on the primo
fascia standard
that
during certain conditions higher speed
may be acceptable
does that answer your question
yeah thank you thank you
thank you
mr lambert had better questions we
talked about 93
when we did legislatively increase the
speed limit from 65 to 70 on the
northern portions of 93.
part of the conversation before we
raised any more
and the understanding was that the
average it takes about five years
of study when you make such a change to
find out if there's really any adverse
effects from from the change
two-part question how fresh my memory
how long has it been since we did that
and
is there any data available
showing
any change
that's a detriment
thank you for the question mr chairman
um
i could find out pretty easily when the
change was done i i want to say it was
2013 or 14 time frame um
i don't want to start digging into files
now because
it might take a little a minute but it
it was at that time frame and i remember
the year following that change there was
a a bill to increase
the speed limit i think on 89 and maybe
101 to that same 70 and at the time we
testified that it would be good to give
us some time to determine if
that had changed
as i said we did a before and after
study one year before and one year after
so we've got data but the data is not
what i would call robust
research data because it was only on
those points north of concord we didn't
have any control on other highways to
see if there was a corresponding
change and in the data that we did
collect north of concord in that
following year
it looked like there was
one section north of franconia notch
where the speeds increased by about five
miles an hour
but on everything else in that first
year there wasn't
there wasn't a significant increase it
was uh it was rarely less than the
previous speed but it was never more
than one or two miles an hour over what
was previously recorded but again those
are
point in time they're not necessarily
robust data over over an extended period
uh the other thing that we wanted to
follow up with was crash volume and
crash severity and that data is harder
for
i don't manage it so i can't necessarily
comment on that but my understanding is
that the crash data is
is inconclusive because
over the years we get more of a
percentage of crashes in what we capture
in the data so
the the increase in the volume may be a
reflection of just having better records
than an increase in crashes so it's hard
to tell if that changed and again that
would be somebody else that would have
to comment on that
thank you for that
i guess while i'm just getting at what
you just mentioned the crash
and the crash severity i guess that's
the important information if there's
anything you can find on that and share
it that'd be fantastic
i see representative cleaver with his
hand up
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
the fiscal note lists uh some 700 signs
and a cost of 178 000
to make the changes
so the first part of the question is do
you agree with those numbers
the second part of the question is that
the law says the bill says
60 days to change out all the signs
and i was wondering if you thought that
was realistic
um
thank you for the question uh i put
together the fiscal note so i guess i'm
gonna have to say that i do agree with
it um
i didn't have any precise data to do it
it was
based on some assumptions that i
included in the fiscal note but i was
fairly comfortable with that
um and as far as the taken effect after
60 days when the speed limit was
increased north of concord
um we made that change pretty much in
one day we took all of our sign crews
and and essentially just riveted on
overlay panels on existing signs it
might have been one or two that we we
changed the entire sign out
but it was something that we were able
to do um in that one day time period but
i would note that that last change took
effect on january 1st
uh so we ended up paying time and a half
holiday pay to do something that we
probably could have done on january 2nd
for um for straight time and actually if
i remember right i made the executive
decision to wait until that uh that
second day so that we weren't paying the
time and a half so i would keep that in
mind if there isn't any change
uh one more we do have other people that
speak representative
thank you i'm sorry i just noticed one
thing representative clieber brought my
attention to it mr lambert when i was
looking reading the fiscal note
i had underlined
um the part that said the evaluations
that for um tapers guardrails guardrail
limits etc the evaluation will require
significant engineering study and the
results will likely include
more warning signs needed fewer passing
zones more guardrail
is the time that's needed for that and
the expenses for that included in that
178 000 or the 178 000 is just the sign
changes
that thank you for the question that's
just the speed limit sign changes
the changing and horizontal alignment
signing
probably not going to be that
significant on the divided highways
because they
probably would were designed for that
kind of speed
but it may be more significant on the
roads that are posted at 55 that would
then be 60.
thank
you
further questions mr lambert
see amen thank you very much
thank you
okay representative i see a full list of
attendees
i agree i see no hands right now
okay well
of all the people there would anybody
wish to speak
one house bill 628
let's see it none
close to public hearings
um
you can never win with these things i
hope representative sykes
agrees with me it gives me that that
courtesy you do your best when you try
to estimate the amount of time these
hearings are going to take
so
that being said we do have
a little better than normal lunch
our next public hearing will be at one
o'clock that is
hospital 522 and then we'll have an
afternoon of executive session so
we'll see you shortly thank you
do
because you have no mic though yeah
yeah
i did that before
excuse me brad
representative fox is having trouble
logging in again i don't know if um
brad can send her a new link
i will resend it to her thank you for
letting me know thank you
why choo choo
so this is if you have a new car that's
under warranty that you only have to get
inspected every two years
and when is it considered not new
anymore
well for the language of the bills once
the warranty is over okay it's over now
you have to go back to one year it's
that simple but
now representative fox is not on yet i
don't know what the trouble is
i did just uh resend her zoom link to
her so hopefully she'll be able to get
on soon
my team
that bad
thank
uh
okay i've been opening up the public
hearing on house bill 522 fn
an act relative to motor vehicle
inspections for new vehicles
uh prime sponsors representatives
erosion representation the floor is
yours
thank you mr chair and members of the
transportation committee for the record
my name is peter trojan
i am
state representing rockingham district
14 in the towns of atkinson and placed
out
the prime sponsors you heard of this
legislation
and i'm here to testify on
behalf of this
bill and
asking you to consider
ought to pass
it's a pretty simple bill let me back up
and say for those few in here at home
members at home
that were on the committee you know
you've heard various
iterations of uh vehicle inspection
sticker
and
requirements from getting rid of them
completely to
changing the frequency
so mine's pretty simple and and
i'm going to go into a little bit of
background on on what it
it
hopes to do
it only affects new vehicles
that are on a new vehicle warranty
so if you buy a new vehicle with some
warranty it changes the frequency of
inspection from one year to two years
only while it's on warranty once it's
our warranty it reverts back to the
one-year schedule
to put this in context that's currently
in the country nine states that have no
inspections at all
and some of those states
have
significantly bad winter weather
for example alaska minnesota
montana michigan in iowa or states that
have no inspection at all
we're not i'm not attempting to do that
what i am attempting to do is
give a little bit of relief for new
vehicle owners
to
to go to a longer
time between inspections
this fifth is about half the 50 states
where the frequency of inspection is two
years or longer many of those are three
years longer the state of new jersey
which isn't known to be a
state that has less regulation than new
hampshire new vehicles in
new jersey get five years before they
inspect them at all
so
you might ask yourself well you know why
bother with this well because i think
it's a common sense
way to give some relief in what does
that do
that helps people
it gives a little incentive to buy new
vehicles
new vehicles are safer they're cleaner
from the emissions point of view
and they have
you know state-of-the-art sensors
so that
the driver slash owner of the vehicle
knows what's going on with the vehicle
if there's a problem with the emissions
they're going to have a light that's
going to show that if there's a
problem with the vehicle requiring
maintenance there's sensors that are
going to indicate that as well
so
there's virtually no risk doing this
because these vehicles are new they're
they're the technology is better than a
vehicle that's 10 years old
and um
many of these vehicles today when you
buy a new vehicle
the dealer or the manufacturer provides
up to three years something you can go
to five years i don't know
couldn't name the ones that are doing
that these days of maintenance routine
maintenance so it's not like the
dealership or
is gonna lose out on the service
business because
you're going to come back because it's
on warranty to have them do that
service anyway
so with that um
it's pretty simple bill i hope you
consider it it's this is this is the
most
common sense in my opinion
change of um
inspection frequency that's come before
this committee
and you know i want to point out one
other thing that i failed to mention
in the 1980s
new hampshire was twice a year
inspection
and there was a lot of cry about if we
do that the you know
safety's gonna suffer and there's gonna
be all kinds of
accidents and problems it never happened
but again that went from six months to
one year the trend in the country is to
go to longer frequencies or get rid of
stickers because um vehicles are more
reliable so this is a very very minimal
change that i hope you can support and
with that i'll open
uh
up to anybody that committed may have
some questions
thank you representative
well thank you so i don't even have to
ask representatives
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative trojan
um i do
have a question about the
having it be under warranty i know
manufacturers warranties differ
across the board of
30 000 miles to 100 000 miles and
everywhere in between how is the dmv
going to know what each manufacturer's
warranty is for each vehicle to know
that if they qualify
under this bill
okay
well
that is something that when you buy a
new vehicle the manufacturer supplies
that
document that shows what the warranty of
the vehicle is
so that's that's very obtainable
from everybody
to to the dealerships to the owner of
the vehicle and
certainly the dmv can get a copy of that
that's not a
difficult thing to
ascertain
follow up please
thank you um my only other
concern would be the um
in terms of the verbiage is just the
term new vehicle um i'm wondering
how that can actually be defined because
a new vehicle for all of us could have
different definitions um i've bought a
what i called a brand new vehicle but it
still had um you know 300 miles on it
because they had to drive it up from
connecticut or for example someone who
bought um
a tester vehicle that
a dealership used maybe for six months
um do you think there's a need to
be a little more specific in what a new
vehicle is or am i just um not a car
person
that um i'm asking this question in the
first place
so um you know if the committee had the
you wanted to strike that out they could
do that um
if you read
the the rest of the the change of the
cartoon
it says any new vehicle that is under
warranty and home owned by a natural
person and registered under this title
so
any vehicle that's still on the
the new car warranty would be eligible
to go to the two-year
inspection and let me point out because
they didn't for anybody that may not
know this is for
an individual a private vehicle um
commercial vehicles
you if you look at the verbiage vertical
aircraft you may remember that passing
that last term
um in other
vehicles that are that aren't private
would still be one year so it's just for
vehicles that are used privately
and owned privately
i hope i answered the question
representative fox
yes thank you mr chair thank you
representative trojan for taking my
question
what about new vehicles um
uh that are purchased and the extended
manufacturer's warranty is purchased
with them
i have a 10-year uh
optional
manufacturer's warranty that i purchased
with my new vehicle so with that um
wouldn't would in essence would i be
able to just
inspect my car every two years for the
duration of the warranty
no no this is the intent here is in the
you know it doesn't say manufacturers
have passed actually added that were had
that word added but this the intent of
this
legislation is to
apply to vehicles with the
issued
uh manufacturer's warranty
follow-up please
yes i understand that but i i
believe the question will be raised
um
without some certain terminology or
language
well i'd be glad
or if the committee would be
would um you know entertain changing it
so that we put one word in there that is
under
the manufacturers
thank you
any other questions from the committee
yeah thank you representation
thank you okay as i look into this as we
get started
however we still have
eight people signed up in a dance to
testify
and i also have 28 to 10 knees
possibility of many more than what i
have to testify
is real
so i'm going to leave it uh testimony to
three minutes
okay
that you would recognize
uh scott welsh uh
presenting himself in opposition to the
building
i am not seeing him if he could raise
his hand
i don't see
let's see him other phone call
back to him
one more shot at the end
[Music]
uh chair organized dick horn h-o-r-a-n
also a member of the public as opposed
to wishing to speak three minutes
can you hear me
okay good afternoon okay
yeah just if you can for the record just
please state your name and okay my name
is
dick horan um the founder and uh former
owner of precision imports manchester
new hampshire and currently a
adjunct faculty member at manchester
community college for automotive
and i i would just like to say that you
know
in some instances on these
manufacturers warranties some of them
are as far as
10 years 100 000 miles
which makes it kind of difficult
to ascertain
how long it's uh actually going to be
every two years for that car that's
number one and the other thing is some
of these cars
they don't have sensors that tell you
when the tires are worn out and in this
busy world today many people will jump
into their car to drive
and actually
have bald tires on the car and have no
idea that their tires are ball
a similar thing that
sensors aren't involved something simple
like wiper blades where nobody knows
that they're bad because we have a long
stretch of dry weather and then when you
go to use them they're actually
dangerous for driving these are just a
couple of the things that come to mind
for me having been in the business over
45 years
that we see on a
constant basis
and
i think
having a state inspection every year is
a lot less painful than going to
funerals
thank you sir if you want to take any
questions or
sure
any questions from the committee
i see none thank you very much sir
thank you
okay chair recognizes eric lynn
representing banks auto
in opposition asking for three minutes
i am not seeing them are you
yeah my only my only question is we've
got one two three four five six
phone numbers i'm just hopeful that
we're hoping that
when i call somebody it's not my phone
number without me
i'll ask one more time uh is there eric
lynn
mr chair
can you tell the phone listeners how to
raise their hand
that's a good point uh if you are car by
phone actually
when you get my phone how do you um
start to start
i thought i don't remember which but
star something
does travis know
i do not know hopefully if brad wouldn't
know that helpful
for anybody that's on the telephone how
do they raise their hand again is it
star
we would start six and then start nine
to one mute
star six and star knight
okay so star six if you are crazy
okay
she recognizes tracy barbage
hold on someone just raised their hand i
just unmuted them
one of the phone numbers
okay you should be live hello hello this
is eric lynn can you hear me
good afternoon
hey how are you doing today
all right so um yeah this is eric lin
i've been a technician at uh bank
chevrolet um for
19 years i've had a state inspection
license for 20 years
um so i've uh
you guys can hear me clearly
okay good um so you know over that time
i've inspected thousands and thousands
of vehicles
um
so i got a couple footnotes here um
one big thing um
we have vehicles coming in with 15 000
miles on them um
particular
michelin primacy tire that is wearing
down to cords prematurely and it turned
out that there was a manufacturing
defect
where they were
using too soft of a compound
and we literally have hundreds of these
vehicles coming in
customers just aren't even aware of it
until we say something
but they're coming through and snow
storms and whatnot with bald tires
and they're just definitely not making
it through through two years
we see vehicles that sit
where the brakes will
rust up and get stuck and then they'll
drag and they'll wear down and the
brakes will basically be non-existent
you know at
10 15 20 000 miles
we've had things like axle seals
cv boots that are
leaking or damaged that can spray
lubricant onto the braking surfaces
obviously that's uh you know a huge
factor
you know people people get in accidents
and they can have
bumper covers that aren't secure or
mirrors that are have sharp jagged edges
and you know somebody
walking around that vehicle in a parking
lot might might get caught on that you
know get cut or get their clothes caught
on it
um we got
modified vehicles um
people with uh you know tinted windows
um
i don't know if
we get customers that bring vehicles in
that have their window uh windows on
both sides and their windshield tinted
and if you try driving one of these
vehicles when it's raining or snowing or
nighttime you can't see anything at all
and i really don't want somebody like
that driving
on the highway next to my wife and kid
also people put on you know aftermarket
light bars um where they're just
blinding other drivers um they got wide
tires that are sticking out past the
fenders so
stones and debris can get kicked up and
crack windshields and windshields
there's another thing right there that's
something that has nothing to do with
the factory warranty
they can be broken they can be cracked
now
there's a lot of different types of
vehicle owners out there there's some
people that
nitpick about every little thing and
then there's other people that just
can't be bothered and they don't have
the time
to address anything and um
you know it's
the the annual safety
mr lynn
yes they have lost you but the people i
passed three minutes anyway which i have
unfortunately have to put a timeline so
you can still hear me thank you very
much
okay yeah i can still hear you uh you're
very welcome thanks for listening to
oh me you take questions
yeah absolutely
one question from representative
thank you mr chair and thank you mr lin
for your testimony today i'm interested
to know
um especially since you mentioned those
michelin tires
do you ever do these inspections and
then report problems to manufacturers
prompting a recall
like if you see something coming in on a
regular basis some problem uh as a
result of these infections did you ever
report those to the manufacturer
absolutely that's called a field product
report and our dealership is actually
nationally recognized for being one of
the most
top contributors to that anything that
we see any type of pattern about we will
certainly
um
you know notify the manufacturer we send
them pictures we send them documentation
we send them everything we can get
and absolutely the manufacturer will
take note of this and investigate it and
make a repair or make it aware to other
you know technicians some dealerships
what not but yes these particular tires
have been identified as a problem and um
there's actually a a document a
published document for these tires where
there is a pro-rated replacement
available to help out the customer
thank you so much i appreciate that
you're very welcome i have another
question from the committee of the
airport
okay
thank you mr chair and uh thank you mr
lynn for taking my question
my question is regarding uh recalls
and in your experience
doing this
um especially with new vehicles have you
ever as you've done an uh an inspection
kind of had to let a
person know a customer know like hey you
know you need to do this recall it's
been out recently we need to do it has
that ever happened when you've done
these inspections of new vehicles
that so anytime a customer schedules an
appointment with us and they bring their
vehicle in
um
whether it be the the scheduling team or
any of the service advisors we always
will check through the vehicle history
if there's any open recalls
um
on any any gm vehicle that we that we
get in here um obviously we can't do
that with different manufacturers
but yes every single vehicle that comes
in we check and see if there are any
open recalls
and
we you know make the customer aware of
it and if they have time and if we have
the parts available
we will do it then and there thank you
welcome
cnn thank you very much sir
you're very
welcome okay next up um
chair recognizes john murphy the member
of the public representative himself
opposed to the bill who was uh
asked to speak for two minutes
good i don't see your name but if you
happen to be one of the phone callers
to raise your hand
hello can you hear me there you are good
afternoon hi good afternoon this is john
murphy and uh thank you mr chairman and
members of the transportation committee
for the opportunity to speak and
opposition of his bill
so i am representing myself but i'm also
representing the company that i work for
um
i've
i live and grew up in nashua and i work
for a second generation auto dealership
i work for the tully auto group i'm the
general manager here and we employ 200
plus
workers
i've been in this industry for 40 years
30 of that i was
either working on vehicles or directly
running the repair shops
i'm a former ase master tech and a
former licensed new hampshire state
inspector
i oppose the bill for many reasons but i
just i want to run down a few we've
heard a few things already
but
one of the things is
right off the bat a vehicle's warranty
coverage has no relation to a safety
inspection at all that that there's no
relation there whatsoever
i don't see the difference between a new
or an older vehicle that's driven daily
uh a new vehicle can be driven
you know 15 or 20 000 miles an older
vehicle can be driven the same or vice
versa and it really doesn't matter on
the age of the vehicle
and i know we've reviewed warranty
coverages
um but is it is it the bumper the bumper
warranty is it the drivetrain warranty
coverage which goes to 100 000 miles in
most cases or could even be further
it's very there's too many variables so
that's not very clear to me at all
um and all the manufacturers have
different warranty guidelines so it's uh
that's a that's a tough one to
to
put a time frame in
in addition to that um we obviously we
live in a state with extremely difficult
road conditions and it's not from a lack
of effort from the state or the towns
it's just it's it's challenging seasonal
environments that we live in and we see
it we we live it we know it
um that's just that's that's the
environment which we live in
i do have a few items that i wanted to
mention and they've they've kind of you
know dick haran brought some up mr lin
brought some up we talked about wiper
blades and lamps and tires
tires can be you know damaged from a
pothole there can be a nail on a tire
that's that's uh rendered it unsafe and
you'd never know that
mr lin talked about brakes rusting if
the car sitting
and whether the car is new or used i
want to reverse to that um
the brakes and the tires are going to
wear out it doesn't matter what the age
of the vehicle is so
it's um
i'm a little confused that the bill and
i and i don't think
um you know that that
mileage or warranty changes the aspect
of safety and what's going to happen to
a vehicle so
but i that that's my that's my
opposition and i would love to answer
any questions you might have um you know
i again i'm just trying to i'm trying to
make sense of the bill um vehicles are
on our roads being driven every day and
uh they are wearing out and getting
damaged and you know failing in
different aspects and that's just part
of driving a car
so i welcome any questions thank you any
questions from the committee
saying done thank you very much
thank you
jay recognizes tracy boravage
representing the new hampshire
motorcyclist rex organization
i'm here can you hear me see me good
afternoon we can hear you good afternoon
and hello again i feel like i was just
with y'all so i am tracy boravage as you
know president of new hampshire
motorcycle rights
motorcyclists are included in hb 522 and
as president of new hampshire motorcycle
rights organization
we are opposed to hb 522.
uh i'm not going to bore you so
everybody else has touched on this again
one of the biggest things as to why we
are opposed to this has to do with tires
specifically the back tire of a
motorcycle
um
they're they're not included in the
warranties typically
and the rear tire of a motorcycle
can wear out for a lot of different
reasons um how a rider rides determines
a lot about a rear tire on a motorcycle
the roadway determines that
how much weight a rider carries on their
motorcycle so some of the full dressers
whether they've got a passenger
what they carry whether it be
tents and everything else that they
carry to go someplace like if they're
going out to sturgis
how many miles they put on it and i can
assure you i put a lot of miles on my
motorcycle and had to replace a tire
uh in a year so we feel a rear tire is a
safety issue
we want to know as a motorcyclist that
all the motorcyclists out there are safe
we want to know that other vehicles that
are on the roadways with us are safe
one of the reasons we created the task
force and the live free ride smart that
i showed y'all earlier
was we want to educate riders we want to
educate the other roadway users we want
us to all be proactive in trying to
create an environment where we are
helping people to not have crashes
instead of reacting to them afterwards
so
in a short
little synopsis
we are against
um hb 522 because we want to have
everybody riding safely
so
with that i'll take questions if anybody
has any questions
thank you any questions
thank you again
thank you very much
shane recognizes director belecki new
york department of vehicles
good afternoon again um mr chairman
members of the committee again for the
record my name is elizabeth bialecki
director of motor vehicles for the
division of motor vehicles i speak today
in opposition to this bill
i do strongly believe that the policy
that you have set in place really
translates on directly translates to the
safety of vehicles on the roads in new
hampshire i have sent you some data that
i also pull up on my screen in a second
and we'll be able to speak to some of
the data that really supports that
and i don't want to repeat the things
that have been said um but i do want to
highlight just a couple of things that
really are technical issues for me and
i'm not unsure how we're going to
interpret those um so again no
definition of a new vehicle
um under warranty what type of warranty
is it manufacturer's warranty is it an
extended warranty is it a
bumper-to-bumper warranty
there are just different types of
warranties and the bill does not define
also owned by a natural person not
defined what does that mean for
businesses there was a great question
that was posed as far as how do we
ensure that we know which vehicles are
subject to this exemption and which ones
are not i don't know how we can control
that so what i could foresee is that we
provide the guidance to the dealerships
and they determine
really whether the vehicle gets a
one-year inspection or or a two-year
inspection based on the guidance from
this bill
so just some technical issues as a
result we really were not able to
determine the fiscal impact on this
because we really don't know the scope
of vehicles that this will include
i think it also could have some
contractual implications
as you know we have a contract currently
for the inspection program that contract
and the price per inspection was based
on the number
of some assumptions one of them was how
many vehicle inspections are performed
in the state um i think it would require
some legal review but there is a
potential that that could change as well
so i just wanted to bring that to your
attention
finally i will tell you that i am
personally an example of the tire issue
so i bought a vehicle almost exactly two
years ago and when i inspected it last
year in june i was told that i will
probably not make it through the winter
so in october so i had to buy
new tires for a vehicle that had about
18 000 miles on it so with that i just
really
want to quickly share my screen and you
should have this
in your mailboxes but i do want to go
through this and just highlight some of
the safety data that i'm that we have
pulled together for you and i think many
of you are familiar with this because we
typically present this type of data
right here about safety inspections but
it shows you the top components that
typically fail a vehicle for safety
reasons so if you look at the most
recent year which is year calendar year
2020 we had about 1.5
million vehicles that were inspected
and a little over 200 000 vehicles were
identified with safety deficiencies that
really caused the failure of inspection
so just under 15
um the
new data that i'm really excited to
share with you is really on safety
recall so i believe representative
gorsky had a question on safety recalls
and with this new contract a year ago
we've implemented a new pro
a new contract
for safety inspections um in january of
and a new part of that program included
safety recall notification so something
different that we have not offered in
the past and i presented you with some
data that again translates directly to
the safety on new hampshire roadways
so um over the past 12 months at the
time of inspection we provided almost
200 000 notices to customers that
notified them of 272 000
safety related recalls that were open
recalls on their vehicles
of those recalls that we provided 25 of
those vehicles that were inspected were
model years 2017 and newer
almost 50 percent of those with open
recalls
were model year 2014 and newer
and we gave you a sample of just one
inspection month
so the vehicles that were inspected
during the month of january of 2021
with a breakdown by model year
and how many of those had open recalls
and how many vehicles that involve and
that included so for example
2020 model year vehicles we had 900
vehicles that were identified with an
open safety recall
and identified 1003 open safety recall
items
um i could keep going but i will leave
it at it leave it at that because i know
i signed up for three minutes and i'll
make myself available for any questions
that you might have thank you
any questions
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you director
for taking my question
um i'll start with the chairman first
though because it's a two-part question
are we going to hear from the new
hampshire department of environmental
safety relative to obd issues
i don't have them signed up
representative um okay there's a problem
i think there's a possibility
somebody in the queue is from there but
they're not listed
and the chance that they may not be
director bilecki can you
um
further elaborate on the implications of
this bill relative to new hampshire's
compliance with
environmental safety issues
vis-a-vis obd testing
thank you for the question
representative sykes you always put me
on the spot i will speak not as an
expert on this topic
but i can tell you from my experience
and from listening to the department of
environmental services that this may in
fact have an impact on our ability to
comply with epa regulations and again
please don't quote me as an expert but i
know that
the state does have a plan that they
have we have to submit to the epa to
ensure that we comply with emission
standards and that is based the safety
inspection and emissions inspection
component is a big part of that plan as
well
i think that's about all i can speak to
and sound intelligently on that subject
and i would again refer you to des for
any further questions a follow-up mr
chairman
thank you director um my understanding
of the obd program is that that is a
required one-year inspection currently
and um and that it's
um
this and if i read this bill correctly
it does not address that at all so
technically if we pass this bill as it's
written
persons would only have to bring their
car in every two years but they still
have to bring it in once a year for obd
thank you potentially
either that or um again department of
environmental services would have to
adjust our state plan to address the
fact that we would not be testing as
many vehicles on an annual basis as was
previously assumed
okay
um
thank you
mr chairman quest
finally mr chairman a question for you
would it be possible to
have the department of environmental
services at least present
uh some written testimony after today
that would address this issue more
succinctly no disrespect to the director
none taken
well fair enough if they don't end up
speaking today i did see another hand
we will reach out to them
thank you
sir any other questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much director
thank you
i'm going to circle back because i still
have uh
some of these phone numbers i can't
identify i'll give a final
chance for uh scott welsh
the public who opposes the build
three minutes
if you're there mr welsh you need to
press
star six
let's start nine
to one
correct
i see your hand raised
the chair recognizes tim white
you can state your name and who you
represent sir
can you hear me mr chairman we can good
afternoon
good afternoon sir thank you very much
for this uh this opportunity
um just to follow up a little bit on um
director bolecki's comments and uh
indirectly to representative sykes
question i just wanted to note that um
house bill 522
because it would require a revision
to the department of motor vehicles
inspection rules it would also require a
revision to the um the state
implementation plan
that we currently have with epa
and under that arrangement we would have
to wait until epa approves the revisions
to the state implementation plan before
implementing those changes to the inm
program
that's basically what i
wanted to mention and
thank you once again for the opportunity
mr chairman and i'd be glad to take any
questions
and who was it your representative
i'm the uh the mobile sources supervisor
with the
air resources division of the new
hampshire department of environmental
services thank you sir uh are you open
for any questions
yes
questions from the committee
see you ain't none thank you very much
okay
um anybody that is
uh falling as an attendee if you do wish
to speak for this if you could raise
your hand
again that's my star
six we'll get to you
that's what i thought was going to
happen
chad recognizes jason lapla
answer we're trying to keep as brief as
possible
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
again now good afternoon great thank you
uh and also with the committee thank you
for for listening to me uh my name is
jason mccrory general manager at auto
fair honda i've been here for 26 years
and a big part of my job is to make sure
that the cars on the road are safe
my son was just in a car accident in 93
when the car in front of him lost
control
and you know the items that we are
inspecting at the annual safety
inspection they're not warranty items
they're safety items they're wear items
you've heard from a number of people
from the car dealerships
tires in particular brakes lights these
are really really important safety items
uh in the back of my building are the
tires that we're taking off cars and
many of them are just they're just bald
they don't belong on our roads um the
other thing that i find very confusing
is
the warranty
warranty is time
or miles uh not timing and miles so time
is consistent so you have a three-year
warranty or four-year warranty or a
five-year warranty in some cases you
have up to a 10-year warranty
but it's also limited by mileage which
is which makes it really confusing
um if you have a 20 if you drive 20 000
miles a year and you have a three-year
warranty then you actually have less
than a two year warranty so that would
definitely cause a lot of confusion
so there are at least five different
warranties um
franchise
warranties and
you know volkswagen for example we have
a volkswagen franchise they've actually
changed their warranty three times in
the last five years
so um that certainly could cause some
confusion
i certainly can appreciate wanting to
save people money i like to save money
as well
but if you save 45
um on a safety inspection uh really once
over over a five-year period um you're
saving nine dollars over a five year
period and you know that that 45 is just
not worth
us you know getting our professional
technicians to get eyeballs on the
brakes the tires and the other items
that are really important to keep our
roads safe
the other thing that we do do in many
many cases is prepare customers for
future things so it may pass inspection
today but you might need to save some
money for you know three four five six
months down the road and i think that's
a great service for people
so uh thank you for your time and i am
open for any questions
any questions from the tweet
um
next i'm going to uh
the telephone number last three numbers
seven nine five i certainly don't want
to mention all of them um
you guys see it pulled up if you can
state that's muted
hi good afternoon can you hear me
yeah
we could please stay tuned
that would be great
thank you mr chairman and committee
members my name is ronald pourier i'm
the president owner of bob and sons
automotive uh
on kelly street on manchester's west
side and i'm also a member of the
talking cars with dick and ron we do a
one day thursday morning radio show uh
in manchester as well we've been doing
that for eight years and i'd like to
speak in opposition to house bill 522
there have been a lot of reasons that
have been mentioned that are very very
good
i think that one of the things that we
need to be aware of is that
i'm not aware of any manufacturer's
warranty that covers any wear items such
as tires brakes wipers
any accidental damage that
happens is never covered by the by the
warranty as well uh there obviously is a
lot of confusion about which warranty
and whose warranty and what year did
they give you that warranty so there's
there's a lot of changes a lot of issues
there the other thing that i think is
very important to remember is not only
uh
a lot of has been mentioned about road
conditions and the environment that we
live in but also driver habits the type
of operation is this person an uber
driver are they in the city all day long
are they putting on lots of city miles
which tend to wear out brakes and things
like that so
uh because of that i think it has a lot
of times it has less to do with the
actual car and more to do with driver
habits accidents the conditions the type
of roads that the person is driving on
the winterization treatment that we use
to
eliminate salt and flush and ice i mean
those things raise havoc with corrosion
on many vehicles so
we've i've been in this business for
over 40 years been inspecting cars since
i was a young guy and we i've seen it
all but i'm never amazed by some car
every month that comes in and we're just
amazed that it was even driving when it
came in
uh i'd be happy to uh take any questions
any questions from the clinic
thanks very much
thank you very much
yes you know the hand raised uh all i
have for information is bill
state your full name and who you
represent sir
star night unmute there you go oh sorry
about that
my name is bill gurney owner of gurney's
automotive repair in nashville
and mr chairman and member of the
committee uh thank you i'm in opposition
of the bill
for all the reasons that are stated um
two points i'd like to make quickly if i
may
if you would
just consider whether this bill would
make the
roads in new hampshire
more safe or less safe
and contemplate that
uh i have seen like these other
gentlemen many things that come in with
cars well under
15 20 000 miles that have issues but you
know will we be
more safe or less safe
for me
uh with common sense i say
for me less less less safe
um
second of all
um it's the best deal on main street
for 40 45 whatever it is for inspection
you're getting a professional
they'll go over a car
that
carries your family
and that you want to keep safe
and get some semblance of what's going
on it's
seriously a really good
thing for the for the public and for us
everybody that's on the road so i leave
it with that um
that it's just safety is the number one
concern for us
and i appreciate the ability to speak
and thank you very much
sir would you take any questions if
there are any i would certainly take
questions
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much have a
good afternoon
thank you
mr chair
yep
uh i noticed that um
representative ankerberg was an attendee
he should be able to handle this
you can still watch what's going on if
you need to speak
thank you i'm sorry
okay let's look down the list here
this chair recognizes dan bennett he's
from the new hampshire auto dealers
association
dealers association
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee can you hear me okay
good afternoon
great thank you very much um my name is
dan bennett from the new hampshire auto
dealers association as you know we're a
trade association for the motor vehicle
industry um i will be brief i will do my
best not to repeat um and and thank you
for the uh the opportunity um
we are opposed to hb hb522 just as
you've heard from all the the speakers
prior uh the experts uh the folks who
live and breathe this and see it every
single day so similar legislation to
this bill or different iterations have
been offered over the past um and they
have always failed uh they've always
failed for the right reason that reason
being roadway safety there's also been
analysis of the data and the data proves
that this is a a
a bad idea
director b leckie mentioned the failure
rate of 15 percent for vehicles and i
would offer this
that 15 failure rate is in at least 15
because when my vehicle comes in my
mechanic calls me and says mr bennett
you need new tires and i say go ahead
i'd like to put on i want a safe vehicle
he doesn't record my car as a failure he
puts the safe tires on it gives me a
pass so that 15 number
that's the bare minimum
okay so the number i would actually say
um realistically is probably a little
bit higher so um
you know we've seen other models where
they've moved to model year exemptions
great britain again to data great
britain has a three model year exemption
when finally tested those vehicles have
a 40 percent failure rate that's
incredibly high number of vehicles that
are on the road
the institute for public safety uh did a
study a couple years back they said 12
12 and a half percent of crashes were
mechanical item related um and uh over
850 000 accidents could have been
avoided uh as a result
another
data point i'll bring up pennsylvania in
2009 analyzed their annual safety
inspection program
um
and said because of the program it saved
over 127 to 187 lives just do the annual
inspection
if it saves but one life i think the
programs of value
you've heard from other folks about
value best deal on main street stuff
like that i would say we do the same
with our with our bodies as we do our
vehicles we do an annual physical right
uh getting on a statin once a year is a
heck of a lot cheaper than triple bypass
surgery so preventative maintenance
saves money just like the recall issue
catches recalls
covered under warranty helps make a
safer vehicle saves consumers from money
some money there um
to uh one thing i did want to mention i
sent you all a fact sheet yesterday it
includes a winter severity map okay and
we discussed i heard you know new
hampshire is not iowa uh new hampshire
is not or
other snowier states um you know we
can't compare new hampshire to florida
that's apples to oranges however if you
look at the winter severity map that i
showed you snowier doesn't necessarily
mean more
severe roads winter severity is a number
of factors
and new hampshire you know up in the
corner is actually incredibly low down
on the scale and it's not the same as
even some of those midwestern states
that were referred to um
you know they don't um they don't have
frost heaves they don't have 52 degrees
at christmas and then uh 20 a week and a
half later they don't have frost tubes
and they certainly don't spray liquid
salt water brine on their roads to get
on the bottom of our cars and
deteriorate them so our severe
conditions uh create a very different
microclimate and it's the reason that
all of our new england neighbors
maintain an annual inspection is because
of those those severe weather conditions
a couple of the other things because i
know my time is limited
that i will mention is i did hear about
a new jersey program
new jersey's inspection program back in
2010 uh coming on the heels of a tough
economic time was a state-run and
administered program the state stations
were
staffed by union employees and that
program was dropped not for safety
reasons it was dropped because no an 11
million dollars a year
uh annual cost to the state so our
program which is independent business
folks free market market rate sets the
price is a very very different program
than what um
is in place um in
in that particular example um
the last two things that i'll mention
real quick we do concur with director b
leckie um and tim white from the
department of environmental services
this will put us uh at odds with our
state implementation plan of our clean
air act
potential as we've heard in the past
years when this has been proposed it
potentially puts us at risk for
sanctions on our highway funds money our
agreement is that we will annually test
vehicles 20 years older or newer
this program change or this proposal
changes that cycle
and the epa has not in fact approved
that so the last thing that i'll mention
too is based on this proposal there is
revenue loss it's indeterminal by the
state
but in this in this budget uh you know
scenario or budget cycle that we're in
we should be attentive to revenue loss
but the general fund will take a hit as
will the air pollution abatement fund
which receives a portion of inspection
sticker sales uh into that fund as well
so stu two state funds that uh will
suffer some type of revenue loss so um
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for your time i'm sorry for
how quickly i spoke um but if there are
any questions uh i would welcome the
opportunities to see if i can assist or
provide some information
any questions from the committee
thank you very much
thank you
okay i still see quite a few names up on
the list uh last call for everybody to
speak
to this
in your
hand pressing star six
recognizes tom bracel
thank you mr chair however i was just
waiting for the executive session
oh okay
well seeing no other speakers then
uh i'm gonna close the public hearing
let's go five two two fn
okay
well i schedule an executive session for
two
i think it did pretty well it's 159
however that doesn't afford
myself for the clerk to reset
so uh if you don't mind we're gonna do
it just a ten minute recess and then
we'll get into executing our place
a little record but i didn't mention i
did speak to tim white several times and
he said they were taking
no position
and i should verify that you get new
jerseys
so
that's
okay
second session on house bill 393
not sure
thank you mr chair i motion that we itl
hospital 393.
oh a second
yes i do thank you
um though i understand the reasons given
on why this could be a great tool i
feared put too much burden of worry
on the
department of motor vehicles to verify
and confirm the driver's blood types
all right discussion from the city
[Music]
thank you
representative smith
yes
clerk otias
representative torojan yes
representative hill
yes
representative aaron yes
representative ankerberg
yes
representative gorski yes
representative o'hara
yes
representative true yay
representative sykes
yes
representative cleaver
yes thank you
thank you representative grassy
yes
representative pickering
representative rich
representative tawarsky
yes representative fox
yes
representative stevens
thank you
sorry
okay representative
yes and chairman walsh
yes
what was that who's that
yeah it was representative sykes moved
consent the vote was 19-0 i think right
yes
i'm sorry mr chairman i didn't hear that
bill yeah i can't hear
i guess it helps when i turn the mic on
i'm sorry
this next one up is 583 like a couple
minutes to reset please
rachel efficient i know
executive session on house bill 583
uh relative to kidney dough uh donation
designation on a driver's license
and chair recognizes
representative hill for a motion
uh yes mr chairman i would move to
retain house bill 583
second
starting again
what was the second representative
representative hill do you wish to speak
to emotion uh sure um thank you mr
chairman um i think that
house bill 583
while being a worthwhile goal there are
a few items that need to be researched
and addressed through amendment
and the sponsors have indicated their
willingness to do some of the legwork
with that i would like to
retain um house bill 583
thank you for that i also spoke with the
prime sponsor representative campbell's
he does understand and agrees and is
fine with the retainer
you have the discussion from the
committee
seeing none as soon as the clerk is
ready we'll call the roll the motion on
the floor is to retain hospital 583
representative smith
yes
clerk ots representative teresa yes
representative hill
yay
representative aaron yes representative
ankerberg
yes
representative
yes president o'hara
yes
representative true yay
representative sykes
yes representative cleaver yes
representative great
grace
representative grassy no yes i apologize
representative pickering yes
representative rich
yes representative
sorry yes
representative fox
yes
representative stevens
senator vegeo
yes
and sharon walsh yes
19 to zero
motion to for consent
doesn't need to be retained yes retained
sorry i'm getting ahead of myself sorry
about that
this is the executive session on uh
house bill 583
a couple of minutes please
that's right
i have a question of the chair
process
um does a retain bill
always have to be addressed
in the fall or if the prime sponsor
doesn't bring it anywhere
can it just sit i don't understand how
that all plays out do we have to take an
action is what i'm saying
that's a good question let me confirm
all the team bills have to be reported
out i think the date is november 1st
okay so we will somehow come out with
something november 1st
regardless of what okay thank you that
helps me
the executive session on house bill 174
uh chair recognizes representative
ankerberg for motion
uh thank you mr chairman i make the
motion ought to pass on house bill 174.
say our second second
representative aaron thank you
do you wish to speak to your motion
yes i do thank you mr chairman
from a property rights perspective
there's no reason under the law that a
cat and a dog should be treated
differently
this bill does not change the negligence
standard or create any civil cause of
action
and
all other personal property is protected
under the law that you could hit a
statue of a fake cat and you're required
to stop but not a real cat and that's
why this bill ought to pass
thank you
any other discussion
uh mr chairman
episode 6 thank you yeah i this bill did
pass was hb 1123 back in 2020. uh it's
the same bill there's no change in the
language i i could be in support of this
bill and hope that it ought to pass
thank you representative like so many
we've heard this year so far just
another one that we passed it's a house
position uh it didn't survive the senate
and they're on the bus bills last year
so
all right there's no other discussion
i'll ask the clerk to call roll when
she's ready the motion on the floor is
out to pass
representative smith yes
clerk maltias
representative uh
yes
representative
representative aaron yes
representative ankerberg
yes president foreskin
yes president o'hara
yes representative true yay
representative sykes
yes
representative
representative grassy
yes representative pickering yes
representative rich
yes representative talarsky
yes representative fox
yes representative stevens
yes is that our failure
yes and sharon walsh yes
19-0
representative barron moves consent
objection consent that is
closes the executive session on hospital
and you've heard me say before a couple
of minutes please
the next one uh house bill 224 i did
send out
uh maybe 15 20 minutes ago an amendment
that i got a wellness to draft up for us
if you want to take a minute see if i've
received it
you
um
it's zero four four six h
that number again mr chair
zero four four six each
thank you
okay
open the public here i'm in the
executive session excuse me on house
bill 224
relative to tinted windows
on automobiles
uh chair recognizes
representative hill for a motion
yes mr chairman thank you um i would
move out to pass on house bill 224.
okay is there a second one second
episode erosion seconds
further through the motion
for further left
i would like to move uh
amendment zero four four six h
and speak to that motion yep you give a
second
again
okay
all right thank you
representative my understanding is uh
this
amendment um simply puts us into the
same position that this committee was in
um i guess it's pretty close to 12
months ago
when the bill passed in this committee
14-3
it simply
puts us in line with national standards
for window tinting
i'll add too um i looked at the bill
several times original bill underlying
i didn't see any any changes to it
looked almost identical to me um this is
the exact amendment we had from last
year's as well
and again all it does
i know we've had the conversation of the
certain ways things are measured this
does follow and allow
the
nitsa's the national recommendation and
allowance for 70
like transmittance
uh on the side windows left and right
so
in essence it's the identical build that
we had last year this is the identity
member
of sykes
thank you mr chairman um
so i was one of the three
last year who voted against this bill
even as it is amended i appreciate the
amendment it does improve the bill over
the original version submitted to us
however i i cannot support the bill as
ought to pass even as amended because
of my concern that the
nearly unanimous opposition to it on the
side of public safety
that is
sergeant christopher kelby from the
department of safety was opposed
captain william haynes from the office
of highway safety and also the
department of safety was
also
opposed and my own life's experience
speaks to the
the
importance of being able to make eye
contact with drivers at
um intersections
which uh
sergeant kelby did not disagree with
that statement so for the for the reason
of supporting public safety and my my
feeling that this is
um
not in the best interest of the
overwhelming majority of the motoring
public in the state i will be opposed to
this
motion
thank you
speaking to the amendment
representative smith thank you mr
chairman
those concerns may have been valid on
the underlying bill but with the
amendment
our standards will now match national
highway traffic safety administration
standards and will literally not make
one more car window in new hampshire
darker than what is currently allowed
it will just mean that if you have an
older cheaper car that didn't get the
tent from the factory that is currently
legal in the state of new hampshire you
can upgrade and that's all this means so
i don't see why we should penalize one
portion of the population because they
couldn't buy a brand new car from having
what's currently considered safe and
acceptable by law enforcement on that
car thank you mr chairman
representative
thank you mr chairman um i just wanted
to
as i'm reading the amendment
point out a concern that came up about
the wording on the the
net light transmittance if there's
already
an existing
um
tint on a on a window as manufactured
and then an additional tint is put on
aftermarket um that would then
be harder to clarify what the total
amount is and there was discussion about
the
the net
number
to take into account both issues so i'm
going to have
trouble with this amendment because it
doesn't i don't feel it's clear in that
regard
but thank you
from what i understand representative
the inspection stations do currently
have to check and
it measures if it measures 70 or less
they're good if somebody doubles up it
puts a different
intent on top of another tip and it
fails
it fails that's how i interpret
any other questions on the amendment mr
chair
represents erosion thank you mr chairman
just to clarify uh there was some
concern about
being able to see through this glass for
for law enforcement safety
at the levels we're talking about you
can see through the
it's not like limousine tent where it's
a dark
pretending that you can't see through so
as you heard uh
representative smith say it's
all the new vehicles are at this level
now it's not an issue
to be able to see through thank you
any further discussion on the event
let's see none i'll
call the roll on the amendment zero four
four six h
as soon as she's ready
representative smith
yes clerk votes yes
representative trevor
yes
representative hill
you bet
representative aaron
yes representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski
yes
representative o'hara
yes representative true yay
representative sykes
uh no
representative cleaver no representative
rossi
no
representative pickering yes
representative rich
yes
representative
fox
no
representative stevens
yes
seven no
i'm sorry could you repeat that uh madam
clerk
12 yes seven no
thank you
welcome
okay so the amendment is adopted uh the
motion on the floor is ought to pass as
amended any further discussion
isn't it true
thank you mr chairman
as i read the bill
if you are able to go out and buy a new
car
it may come with tinted windows
and if you can't buy a new car
you can take your old car and put the
exact same tent
on your old car
as a
more
well-off person has on their new car
i don't see any safety issue with that
at all
any further discussion
yes mr chair
representative
to
expound on
representative true's comment
if uh if someone purchases a new car
in
um actually if someone purchases an
older car in massachusetts and puts
that window tint on
versus someone over the border in salem
doesn't put that tind on
the car that's driven from massachusetts
in on new hampshire roads would be legal
the car that's purchased in salem
uh would not be legal if those
if that had window 10 put on it is that
correct
again please i didn't know your ass
could be equipped
ah
um
so my understanding is if a car
in massachusetts an older car puts
window tint on
and drives on new hampshire roads that
would be legal correct
if a
car in salem new hampshire
same year same everything
put window tint on
of the same type
and drove on new hampshire roads that
would be illegal
correctly yes
doesn't seem like a safety issue to me
either
further discussion
all the world when she's ready the
motion on the floor is out to pass as
amended
representative smith yes
votes yes
representative trojan yes representative
hill
yes president
yes representative ankerberg yes
president
yes president o'hara
yes representative
yay representative sites
no
sorry about the sneezing
representative cleaver no
representative rossi no
representative pickering yes
representative rich
yes
representative
no
representative fox
is that stevens
no
representative
twelve to seven
regular calendar it goes
session on house bill two two four few
minutes please
mr chairman when are committee reports
due
um as soon as you can get them to me do
you still have the template
uh actually that was for anybody that's
made a motion today uh do you still have
the template from last exec session that
was sent out or do we need to send a new
one
uh i can't swear to it
you want to
just get on your search search at the
top
yes
mr chairman
um there will be a minority report but i
don't believe we will necessarily debate
the bill
do you still have the template i sent
you i believe i can find it if not i
know how to find you okay
representative sykes will you be doing
the minority report
yes i guess i'll take care of it thank
you
mr chairman so we could also be prepared
too is there any way you could announce
which one we'll be taking up next as the
clerk gets ready oh i'm sorry i thought
i already did house bill 116.
thank you
[Music]
okay
um
search
the executive session up on house bill
116.
chair
recognizes representative smith for a
motion
thank you mr chairman and move to the
senate house bill 116.
is there a second
would you like to speak promotion super
brief yep
thank you
there are going to be more stakeholders
that are going to give us more technical
information on the specific devices that
they want to deploy in new hampshire and
this is the room full of people that i
hope can work with them so you've got
the center to finish product with
feedback from
everybody in the fall thank you
thank you further discussion
see you done if you're ready
representative smith yes
clark coats yes representative frozen
yes
representative hill
representative aaron yes representative
ankerberg yes
representative
yes
is that o'hara
yes representative true yay
representative sykes
yes representative cleaver yes
representative grassy yes representative
pickering yes
representative rich
yes representative
yes
representative fox
yes he's done stevens
yeah
yes
and chairman walsh yes
who's consent
yes
not to retake
next up will be hospital 78.
i did find the template by the way mr
chairman
whether it's doing a report it doesn't
happen
send me an email
so
all right
open the executive session on house bill
see relative to certificates of title
driver's licenses for members
of united states foreign service chair
recognizes
representative
crawford for a motion
mr chair i make the motion to retain
a second house second represents erosion
um i believe that um
director
olecki said that we could work together
on this bill to make it a better bill
and hopefully be successful
in allowing those diplomats to retain
their new hampshire license or be able
to renew their new hampshire license
when they're overseas so i'm hoping that
we can come to some
um agreement and
make it work so it's not to pass later
on in the year
any other discussion
thank you mr chair i'm relieved that um
there's a effort to work on this i think
it's a problem that has to be fixed but
the fix seems more complicated than what
could easily be done so i will support
the retain
any further discussion
saying that
the chairs ready should call the roll
motion on the floor is uh retained for
elsewhere 78 representative smith yes
claire coats yes representative
torrenson yes
representative hill
representational
sorry yes
representative aaron yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative
yes
senator o'hara
representative true yay representative
sykes
yes
is that a cleaver yes
representative grassy
yes representative pickering yes
representative rich
yes
representative
representative fox
yes representative stevens
yes representative
yes
and chairman walsh yes okay 19 to zero
15 0.
here's the executive session on house
bill 678 next up house bill 329.
what's up
i see your representative
it's all home day and transportation
representative
good to be here it's like we never left
despite the old advantage that you never
can go home again it's good to be home
okay open up the executive session on
house bill 329
my title here to the official relative
to storage of rail cars containing
hazardous materials
our chair recognizes representative
o'hara for a promotion
emotion for 329 that we itl
we have a second
second
okay
i wish to speak to your motion
yes thank you um i feel that we all
understand the concerns of the citizens
in the area of the storage bank but the
risk of cold winters without heat to the
citizens up in coast county and other
northern counties
in new hampshire would be put into an
even higher risk with this bill
lastly this bill would make the tank
parts move every 72 hours which would
increase the risk of bills
thank you sir any further discussion
uh mr chairman
representative
yeah i'm in agreement with this motion
of itl i it puts me a little bit of a
difficult pickle with my local
constituents having one of these storage
areas in downtown west lebanon that said
it's clear to me that the
greater good for the majority of the
citizens of new hampshire
would
suggest that this bill should be itf
sir
any further discussion
uh the clerk is ready to call the world
emotion on the floor it's uh ito on
house bill 329. representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative torreson
yes
representative hill
there you go
yes
representative aaron
representative
yes
representative gorski yes is that o'cara
yes is that it true yay
representative sykes
yes
representative cleaver yes
representative grassy yes representative
pickering yes representative rich
yes representative
yes representative fox
yes
adam stephens
yes representative
yes
karen walsh yes okay
now move consent
uh consent's been moved by
representatives erosion
any objection
consent goes
book the executive session on health
bill 329
next up house bill 279
um
few minutes to reset and i just want to
double check with everybody we were
given a
draft amendment proposed amendments uh
when this bill was heard does everybody
still have that
should i say why don't we look for it um
23.
20 21 03 198
it was drafted by representative pearl
um mr chairman can
um was that sent to us via email or have
i got a moment to look it up online
it was email but it was when the bill
was heard
no let me let me look thank you i
appreciate just a moment okay
i'm actually gonna help just in case
everybody did look it up
i also just resented the entire
committee if anyone has trouble finding
it
oh
thank you mr chairman
amen
okay has anybody had a chance to review
the amendment
open up the executive session on house
bill
uh chair recognizes representative eric
for a motion
thank you mr chair
um
i move that we uh ought to pass this
bill and with an amendment and uh the
amendment is uh the zero three let's go
yeah let's see sorry so that's the pass
so let me get out let's get a motion for
the octave second for the autopsy
second by representative smith
uh this is open to further amendment do
you have another motion i do i move uh
the uh to
pass the amendment which is uh zero
three one nine h
and as amended this amendment for this
bill increases the maximum gross weight
allowed on any truck or trailer
combination that carries raw forestry
products
such as unprocessed logs and wood chips
loaded on the log landings
this bill is a big benefit to the forest
product industry because the
drive axle weight limit being requested
in this bill
is consistent with our neighboring
states and other truck configuration tax
limits
this bill is supported by the department
of safety the timberland owners
association the new hampshire farm
bureau and the new hampshire motor
transport association
the forest harvesting industry has spent
a significant amount of time and
resources
trying to comply with the current
statute and this change will allow them
to continue to operate safely
without being subjected to onerous
further regulations on the amendment
okay
i'm seeing none this will call the rule
on the amendment uh motion on the floor
is to adopt amendment
2021-2319-h
representative smith yes
kirk votes yes representative carlson
yes representative hill
yes
instead of aaron yes representative
ankerberg
yes
representative
is that o'hara
yes
representative
yay representative sykes uh
representative sykes votes reluctantly
yes
representative cleaver no
representative grassy no
representative pickering yes
representative rich
yes representative trulersky
yes
representative fox
no
representative stevens
yes
representative
and chairman walsh yes
16-3
okay the amendment is adopted
the motion now is out to pass as amended
in the discussion
on the bill representatives
sorry about that
um i voted reluctantly for the amendment
because it is a slight improvement over
the original bill that was submitted
and while i recognize that this
there's
some very good reasons for passing this
i am
equally concerned that
as new hampshire's dot's funding
situation gets worse and worse and worse
and
where we find less and less money
available to maintain our roads
and that the time frame between
repairs for roads is lengthening out and
lengthening out
um that's a big concern for me on top of
that
when the roads start to degrade
um
that has an impact on people's personal
automobiles because if the road is bad
then it takes
adds additional wear and tear to your
shocks uh
not that i'm a mechanic mind you
whenever i do tool stuff blood results
usually mine
but
nevertheless i know that bad roads can
lead to further deterioration of your
vehicle
um
and
let's see there was one other point i
wanted to make
um
oh goodness
well
if it comes back to me i'll raise my
hand again but for the moment anyways i
wanted
i would make clear that i'm opposed to
the bill
further discussion from the committee
i'll add something on this um
i looked at this at the beginning not
sure what to think
but as we had the hearing it just
started becoming easier and easier to
support this
um even with the increase of 40 000
pounds per axle it puts us
actually in the middle of the road if
you excuse the transportation
of the two northern states within the
states up north vermont and maine
uh and i can certainly see where we've
been significantly lower and truck
weights would be a problem for anybody
that does business over the borders
i also understand a little bit on how
these trucks are loaded uneven surfaces
the materials they put in them are not
always easy to
perfectly in
these trucks
and then i was surprised to see how many
businesses a change like this could help
so the only thing i still had left as a
concern is what it might do with the
roads and it was during the testimony
that we heard it was a great question i
don't know who asked it
but they said is this going to increase
the frequency or require the roads to be
repaired at a higher frequency than they
currently are and the answer was no
so
uh i thought that was the department of
transportation
so
it was mr rodriguez i didn't write it
down but that he was the only one who
testified against it that day
so for all the reasons i i don't see
this
as a problem and i asked the committee
to support the otp
thank you mr chairman my poor feeble
brain finally remembered the other point
that i wanted to make um
one of my concerns too is
this will begin a carve out procedure
for
various industries to no longer comply
with
certain requirements
we've seen this in other industries
where we had an original
weight limit posting for roads uh that
was for essentially all trucks but
we carved out
fuel trucks and then ultimately we also
carved out milk trucks and
this i worry that this is a slippery
slope
that we go down and so that was the
other point that i wanted to make
thank you
thank you sir
any further discussion representative
anytime you represent we can't hear you
there we go
now we can
i guess i doubled it
um anyways i just wanted to say that i
i'm voting in support of this bill
partially
out of being educated by my own
constituents
i didn't have any prior knowledge going
into
the advisability of this
but when my local constituents educated
me as to how it actually affect
the logging industry which is quite
important in one of my towns
it convinced me that this bill is worth
passing so i will be voting yes
further discussion
yes mr chairman i did find a note from
that i took relative to the testimony of
dave rodrigue from the new hampshire
d.o.t
and one of the things that he did say
was that a 10
weight increase
yields a one and a half times increase
on the impact on roads
and he also brought up the concept of
you know
adding you know different
adding different industries to the
exemptions make it more difficult
for compliance even
but anyways thank you sir
thank you
any further discussion
alaska clerk call the roll
promotion on the floor is about to pass
as amended on house bill 279.
representative smith
yes
clerk votes yes representative torreson
representative hill yes representative
aaron yes representative ankerberg
yes
president
senator o'hara
yes
representative
yay
representative sykes
no
representative cleaver
representative grassy no
representative pickering yes
representative rich
yes
representative trulersky
no
representative fox
representative stevens
no
representative
yes
and chairman walsh yes
13 to 6.
closes the executive session
representative sykes actually did very
well in the objection or the objection
from anybody to tackle a couple more
uh i'd like to take care of uh house
bill 104
and 461. um
we heard this morning which is
just
the returning bills that we passed last
year
[Music]
oh yes and 104 was a steady commission
on personal rapid transit
so mr chairman thank you for um checking
in with me
as a matter of
general concern i i don't like um
executing bills on the same day that we
hear them that said i i don't
see that we'll have any particular
problems with either of these bills but
i will just continue to make my
concerns noted that it's better to
have some time to
to
absorb the arguments that we heard and
if we had further questions to check in
with the people who
um
testified and then vote on it so
objection noted
there we are
fair enough and i think i've been fair
all along um i wouldn't take these two
up if i thought there was any question
on them
i just think uh
because one's already house position and
the other one i think they'll be fine
with the motion
um
just actually
helps me and helps the committee just
move along with our processes and i've
been very cognizant to make sure
everybody's got the time to do their
research
so
that being said
open up the executive session
and the chair recognizes
representative smith for a motion thank
you mr chairman i moved to retain house
bill 104
have a second
second
okay i got three
representative crawford that you put you
both first
but you wish to speak emotion
yeah uh same rationale as last time i
don't need the committee to accomplish
the goal which is to get manufacturers
and conveyors of these interesting
systems to come in here present and get
a group of people that i know will make
a good decision to decide if it's
vaporware or not
there's one that might be interesting
that's based in new hampshire a
lightweight rail system i don't need
that involved i need you all to help us
see if there's anything we can do
so
we'll put the move
and take
thank you mr chairman um i would i would
vote in favor of this
retaining motion um that i appreciate
representative smith
and the hard work that he's trying to do
on these these types of issues i have
always believed that
one of the important roles of the
transportation committee is to to take a
look at
um
different transportation
problems and how they may be solved
rather than just specific types
um
and so
and also that we should be always be
looking at
improvements in technology that will
help
our citizens and and the transportation
related issues so with that i would vote
to retain
sir
discussion from the committee
senator hill is that your hand or no
put your hand all right but
i don't think it's raised
all right
no no further discussion i'll ask the
clerk to call the role which is ready
motion on the floor is to retain those
bill world war representative smith yes
votes yes representative torreson yes
representative hill
yes
senator aaron yes
representative ankerberg yes
senator forsky yes representative o'hara
yes representative true yay
representative sykes
yes
is that a flavor yes
is that a grassy yes
yes
is that a bridge
senator fox
yes representative stevens
yes is that avail
yes
and chairman walsh yes
i know
house bill 461
again just past legislation house house
um position currently i thought it was
probably one of the simplest bills we've
had this year i know we can do this
a few minutes
to reset
okay
open the executive session up on house
bill 461
and that is america's bill two bills
from last year
relative to motorcycle auxiliary lamping
adding new motorcyclist rights
organization to the traffic safety
commission chair recognizes
representative smith for motion and this
is kind of fun what a switch
thank you mr chair i move ought to pass
on hospital 461. can i get a sense of
representation
would you care to listen okay motion
yes
so this two-part bill one will add the
new hampshire motorcycle rights
organization
safety commission where after their long
commitment to motorcycle safety and
working developing training programs
they will be an asset and the second
part of the bill regarding lamping
is a kind of a nothing burger it simply
updates new hampshire statutes to meet
the national highway traffic safety
administration's standards for what is
acceptable by the iran website
that's it positive six
mr chairman i just got around to raise
my hand well what he said
uh
with a minor exception about the nothing
burger part i think i would cut that out
but
i'm in support of the motion
thank you any further discussion
see how you're done i'll ask the clerk
to call the roll when she's ready uh the
motion on the floor is about to pass on
house bill 461. representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative torreson
yes representative hill
yes representative aaron yes
representative ankerberg yes
senator forsky yes president o'hara yes
is that true yes representative sites
yes
is that a cleaver
is that a brassy
yes is that a pickering yes
is that a bridge
yes you gotta have tolerance gate
yes
is that in fox
senator stevens
yeah representative
yes and chairman walsh yes
i heard that move to consent
yes
no objection consent that
the executive is on house bill 461
agreements it's only 10 past three we
could do another half a dozen
but we're not
just a couple of notes for the good of
the cause before we go
uh you've probably seen it there's only
three bills that made it in the calendar
this week i did some inquiring and it
looks like several of the committees
were dealing with the same thing it
looks like the early bills which is what
the bed line is looming for for these
two days uh they did take priority uh so
we would have an overly extensive
calendar we do have more processed uh
they're just waiting for the next
calendar
uh in terms of our schedule those two
session days of putting a change on to
that also
i
believe
and again this
is what they'd even say because i'm not
sure
where we stand now we only have three
bills left to here we're in pretty good
shape
uh so my plan is for two more days
we can hear our first three bills
do some executing on the ones we've
heard today and i think there's one or
two that are still in limbo
then not the following day one other day
just to do an executive session mop up
if you will for any bills and of course
i'm going to leave some time in between
uh between the three that we hear and
the exact session as much time as i can
again it's because of the 24th and 25th
that's changing the schedule i haven't
got a definitive answer on what days
this room is available to me yet but i
will let you know the second that i do
so that's where we're at
can i ask a question about schedule
sure
just looking at the calendar um i know
that there's the deadline to pass things
off is it the
march 11th
so that means we have to be all done
before march 11th
okay there was there was a probably an
oversight by everybody thursdays used to
be the end of business because we never
did business on friday before uh in
hindsight we could have made a change to
make the deadline of the 12th therefore
we could have met on the 12th
didn't happen so yes that second and
second week there's a very good chance
um well not a very good chance the
definite chance will be having her
prior to the 11th
and then my other question is
oh i'm sorry chairman
um my other question is is is there
usually a little bit of lag time before
we start getting bills
from the senate
yeah there is uh but if it's any
consolation i've heard
through sources that we're not going to
be seeing many i heard the number three
being mentioned
i agree because i was looking that's why
i was wondering if we might have a
little break
yeah i believe we will i can't tell you
how much for certain
but only three bills on our plate uh i'm
sure we can budget in a break
thank you
any other questions
all right cnn have a good weekend
everybody thank you very much if you've
got you owe me committee reports
um actually everybody who knows me at
committee report is online
so i guess i get something to do when i
get home
actually i owe you one for a minority
report mr chairman uh one more time
yeah i do owe you a minority report on
two two four i'll get that to you within
the hour
okay thank you
mrs
as soon as possible
representative sykes is there going to
be a minority report on
the 279 or not
i hadn't intended to do one but feel
free if you wish
to i'm fine i just wanted to double
check
representative erin's gym um